[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yo
we back you thought it was over
but we back let me know if my levels is
good
sega kid stand up say it say it
say it let me know about levels is good
they will not stop the movement
joanna dog what's going on hustle and
motivate what's going
on baby all the levels good nicks what
up
be lou what's up yes you already know
they try to stop us the fanboys try to
stop us but the sega legacy
shall we go we already know
much love much love hustle much love but
lord metroid was up in there first man
salute back today what's going on yeah
we're gonna get people in the room
a lot of sega talk you know what i'm
saying i'm very curious to see um
which console i think i know which
console might get the most out of the
out of the legacy but i think there's
going to be some surprises
some underrated love and games you know
what i'm saying from certain generations
to say that we're going to get to it
say it my man be lou let's talk i'm
joined it down what's that eternal
champion
okay if you're the oasis glory metro car
don't mess the masses
listen i got a lot of master system love
a lot of tr y'all might have to bear
y'all about to call
time on me for master system love
no doubt nick smith's that genesis tower
of power yeah
so we're gonna get people in the room
just want to make sure the audio was
good
and uh we're gonna have some fun we got
some sega talk yeah it's just
a beautiful day beautiful thing so i
will be back
we gonna pile this room up
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
all right and we are
live back again at the round table it's
time for real
this time for real man the sega love is
in the building i have some tremendous
company with me
man we're gonna talk about some sega
we're going to talk about some
generations we're going to have some
appreciation
some retrospective it's going to be fun
man we're going to keep it casual i got
some good friends but
first i got to introduce of course my
brother on the panel my lord the lord of
all lords the the iron bank man himself
and uh
everything else we i felt like i i've
podcast with you like two times earlier
today but
you gotta be on another video but my man
lord saw man how we doing man
i'm doing great man oh i can't i'm so
happy to be here man like
you don't understand for us sega kids
you know it's always been an uphill
background
especially especially if you're a fan
from the from the hardware days
right like though and it has you know
certain certain aspects of sega recently
have not been great but you know shout
out to yakuza for holding us down yes
but yes yes but um
man yeah i just just to talk the history
of sega
and and and how we all became sega kids
and you know
how how our love for for that brand kind
of came about
is fantastic man i'm glad we're doing
this absolutely absolutely got to have a
roll with me
and of course let's start with the
developer first
this bed again for those who don't know
has one of the
one of the best games out right now it's
actually a multi-platform in-game pass
unto the end a small team but just an
amazing story and well done
shout out to sarah in the room
gotta introduce my man stephen what's
going on man dan how you doing brother
good man uh really yeah like so excited
to be here it's like kind of like a walk
down memory lane really because
really like the formative years and why
i decided to get into game dev and
always dreams of making games just
because of sega so this is like a super
cool thing to be able to talk about
this is great that's what i want to hear
inspirations
that's what i'm talking about man two
ton studios in the building
so glad you could make it brother we are
going to have some fun talking about
these generations
no doubt no doubt and of course we got
to deal with a seasoned gentleman next
gentlemen that uses those in no
introduction one of the most
professional websites going on right now
great podcast in the big cast my man
ainsley bowden how we doing sir what's
happening guys you know we've been
talking about this for a long time
uh i know me you and sav have always
joked about not even joked about sega
talked about sega you can't put it out
there like that
but uh i love how saul phrased it up as
the struggle
of being the second fan factual as a kid
and that's what it felt like at times as
a gamers gaming was a niche but it was
owned by nintendo i know we're going to
get into it but man i've really been
looking forward to this as you can
tell from my backdrop so oh that
backdrop is so clean brother i'm loving
it
[Laughter]
no doubt no dahlia then we got last but
certainly not least
a veteran a person who's been putting it
down
for so long honestly very inspired by
him you know his journey
he really um has has helped me out on my
content creation and
and always willing to give a hand but
more importantly one of the most
purest sega fans i know i had the
pleasure of doing a great sega podcast
with him that he invited me to
so it's only right i extend the
invitation back to
my brother the original oh gee
next level gave it by man mike mullis
how are we doing sir
and you said you weren't going to do any
fancy come on
blush i'm blushing man what's up now
this is part two for us
good this was this one you said hey i'm
thinking
i was like i'm there not even
i told my wife i said four o'clock you
go take a nap i'm good
my wife is actually at the beauty parlor
right now
now this is great great absolute great
company to be in and stephen i actually
have
under the dead in my until the end on my
list of games to get
through so i'm getting ready to get i'm
actually getting ready to get started
with that game so
cool that's awesome to meet you just be
prepared to feel
to feel very old because your skills
will be put to the test
it's very good but it's challenging oh
yes oh yeah it's challenging oh yeah
definitely
if i have to type out this is the dark
souls of i'm going to
put it pretty much get ready it's going
to take you back to those days those uh
one life days and concerts
ah pray all right bring it luckily
there's quick resume where you could
die right at your point look we got to
get into it y'all i mean again so many
let me get these super chat oh yeah
let's get started
with the chat real quick we got gerald
mack five dollar super chat oh i held
the iop and the pantheon panel
great show appreciate the ilp for giving
us a saturday
and a sunday to look forward to of
course sir yes of course
we're looking forward to this then we
have fat boy horror five pound super
chat
at porsche power keep that stuff in the
background man
so much better they like that classic
love they like that
they like you need to you need to do a
seminar on super chat reading man you
are
yeah love listening to him
i need to hook him up with you for some
reason
we're gonna get right into it gentlemen
i think i want to start something
different um
obviously we know we got the consoles
that i have in the back and we got the
generation but i want to start first
you know with sega in the arcade scene
first
and just you know impact it had any
any standouts for you guys i know i'll
start off first i mean
you know for me it was definitely what
really drew me to the brand
um you know as a person as a kid who
went to the arcades the flashy lights
the dim rooms
you know sega to me always stood out
there their
arcade cabinets if you even call it some
of them were just like
literally full on motorcycles with hang
on you know saying you know i think
about outrun and
jumping in the steering wheel the
feedback as a kid it mesmerized me
it made me want to play these games so i
want to give it up to you guys i'm open
for him first whoever wants to jump in
you know some arcade standouts or things
did the rkc resonate with you guys like
it resonated with me with sega
i used to go to the laundromat to play
outrun
oh yeah there used to be a strip mall up
where i'd up where i was and my
my parents would go to one store and i'd
be like i'm going to go over to the
and they knew where i was going
i was going to play outright drop many a
quarter in that
what what soundtrack like what would we
do a splash
i remember first seeing a space harrier
get ready and yeah yeah right before you
died five seconds later
yeah that was that was tough it was
tough yeah but just the scaling of it
you know what i mean it just was
different from
anything else at the time and i remember
just thinking to myself man i got to try
and conquer this i don't think i ever
did
but uh you know there were a lot of
quarters thrown in that thing for sure
that
soundtrack too man that that yeah yeah
that was a kicking soundtrack
it's inspiring like yeah that was yeah
the bullets that like
like big jelly beans yeah yeah i
you know what i mean because you had to
measure the distance between your guy
and it
and it was it was just different i
always loved different things in games
and sega always brought that
too young to like actually lean the bike
so i remember being really
sad as a kid because it looked so
awesome you had this like
full bike and i get on it and it was
heavy enough so you just like dialed in
i also remember i want to know if anyone
remembers this i also remember like a
hologram
hologram game by sega where
and then you'd like warp through like a
door or something go to the next room
and it looked it like time travel
because it's like time travel time
travel time travel
star wars holographic chess that's kind
of what it was like but realized like in
a game
when was it it was like the 90s or 80s
1991
okay yeah so early 90s i've ever seen
that in the arcade
and just like my it's like my mind was
just totally blowing man it was amazing
yeah
yeah absolutely shout out to kavaz in
the chat he's he loved the hang on love
he said reaching the night level and
hang on
man but for me it's the same way like i
think you know all of us
the love of sega comes from the arcades
right and and just like you said cog
it was that thing of you know you played
the midway games you played your pac-man
you played you know whatever it's
pac-man you're
you're whatever your nintendo games
don't whatever
but sega was just another level like
even the
even the really old stuff i don't know
if you guys remember like the original
like monaco gp
oh yeah sure yeah and it wasn't like it
wasn't a first person game it was just a
top-down like racer
but the cabinet for it was like this
elaborate super like
and i'm like what the hell is this like
i can't i can't believe and then of
course like the first time i saw zach's
on right
and zach's on 3d yeah and those things
like
those were very early games but these
cabinets were so elaborate
that you're like i have to spend money
on this i have to see what this is
and then once they started you know once
you once you got like to the model one
board and stuff like that and the super
scalar stuff
uh for me the one that really really
really blew me away
was afterburner yes oh yeah
unbelievable because i don't know if you
guys ever saw because there was one that
was just
it was just the cockpit and it didn't
move then there was the other one that
was humongous
yes exactly and i remember over here on
the east coast we have um a place called
six flags great adventure right
yep so back then i don't know how it is
now but back then they had an entire
building essentially dedicated to to be
an arcade
um it was amazing and every time we went
there
like my parents get mad because they
want us to get on the rides i'm like i
want to spend like an hour in the arcade
and it was because it was the only place
that had those types of machines those
humongous machines so whatever we we'd
go once or twice a year
and we spent so much time there but it
was that machine that really said to me
like
whatever sega does i'm there like i mean
it was it was that's really the love
came from earlier on
but that sort of stuff really made me
say good kid because nobody was touching
them in that regard yeah no one thing
i think was like a dollar to play too
yeah it was
it was a dollar and then you had the the
six flags tax
oh yeah i mean and you remember the
remember the one
there was a it wasn't a sequel but then
they came out with this game g-lock
that was sort of like like afterburner
but with the true 3d
oh man oh yeah oh yeah yeah i mean
for me i would be remiss if if i did not
mention the arcade shinobi
that game changed my life you know the
story everybody here mostly knows
the story but it it truly was because
again it was like you know first of all
you learn at a young age
the discrepancy between an arcade
version
and a console
i was able to stand we will get to mass
system we will get to jettison but
you know i was able to discern that what
i'm playing right now
is completely different but the thing
that amazed me you know
i i just felt it was one of the perfect
games because it was very difficult
the music was fantastic you know what
i'm saying whoever and it wasn't
correct me for wrong mike that wasn't uh
a boy user uh
it's a very obscure person that did that
music
and i think honestly i know i know we we
give our boy you
you know all the credit streets and
razor stuff but i still
feel arcade should only have one of the
most perfect soundtracks like almost
every uh you know song kawakami
yeah i believe and it was amazing
besides that i said the difficulty and
let's be real it's
it's the 80s it's ninja craze karate
like that was the thing you know what
i'm saying and like i said i'm just
being mesmerized by
people playing it and and knowing at one
time i'm like look
i got to get good at this game you know
and be going to the local arcade and
having that guy that was just so
dominant to beat it on one quarter and
i'm like i gotta have this
kind of thing but that's my name's sake
and everything was well but shinobi
arcade truly resonated with me i
absolutely loved that game
you know don't forget too that there
were and i know people in the chat i
mean they're they're going no love for
golden axe and stuff and and those were
those were the staples don't forget this
this is the company that also put out
commando
which was a a game that that that you
just went back and played
and congo bongo
in that time when when donkey kong was
like the big thing and sega needed
something to to go against it and
and i still like that's one that
i emulate because i
love that game the game was so hard but
it was so
fun an older one
another before i i had you know uh
sega console you know my first console
was the coleco right and the coleco
would take some of the um
titles for the arcade click was a weird
system because they had like a lot
nintendo on it sega on it they had all
these different people that
eventually but i don't know if you guys
remember it was an arc it was called
turbo
y'all remember turbo it was almost like
uh sega's
version of pole position in a way like
that that rrkd
racer you know you can't really hit the
other cars and i remember being
very impressed by that game and again
another arcade game that came out
obviously the chat is
is going in about you know altered beast
and then gold and that i mean those
we're gonna get there
but i just want to get some obscure ones
any obscure ones out from the arcade
that you guys also remember before we
move on into the console generations of
sega any other arcades ones that
resonated for you guys
actually i wanted to know something on
golden golden fantasy zone yeah was was
uh incredible i just wanted to note on
gold golden axe that i think the console
version
made me kind of because i don't think
the console version was nearly as as
good as the arcade one
yes and i think that it made me kind of
like forget about
golden axe a little bit because of that
and i think that's an interesting thing
that happens you know for people that
maybe experienced it for the first time
only on console and never saw an arcade
yes probably changed his perception now
but fantasy zone yeah i remember playing
that game and this is so such a
weird super you're like a flying egg
with wings and like the
world was like like acid trip
it was like crazy it was bizarre right
it was just super bizarre it is this
game
but yeah you know i got fantasy zone two
somewhere wherever i can point yeah
um games are just amazing they're all
colorful and and
unique and different and fun and yeah
i love those games i'm glad you're glad
you brought up turbo because
i had that on the colecovision with the
wheel we came with the
yeah man oh yeah plug that into the
expansion drive that's a that's the
collector
that'll be a coleco appreciation
retrospective we can do that for a while
but look for sure so arcade we got
so we gotta transition y'all we gotta
transition
to that uh that red and a red and black
right there that red and black right
there and uh
you know a very very beloved system for
some you know that had it but um i'm
actually gonna
defer to our aims here man i wanna know
his his his his we see it behind him as
well
the master system the sega master system
you know what did that i want to start
with the console before we get to the
gate i want to start with the console
first
and your appreciation for it yeah so uh
we
we don't have to get into story time
because i can sit here and talk about it
all day but i uh you know i
had atari growing up right and then i
went over to a friend's house
in 85 and he had gotten nintendo and
super mario brothers which i'd never
seen before
and blew my mind right um but i think
like many of us who talk about those
days
my i live with my mom she's a single
parent and didn't have much money right
so um the next year
she saved up and she went to buy me a
video game system and no joke we went
into it
we lost aids oh hey
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
sorry i'm sorry so what i was saying is
um my mom didn't have much money
couldn't get a game system right the
next year she had a credit card at a
uh department store called boskovs which
if you're familiar with the east coast
you know
um and she literally picked up a sega
master system and brought it home to me
because she didn't know any different
right um so i i didn't really know much
of the time either but i can just tell
you that you know i was the only
person i knew that had a sega master
system
um but she had this uh deal and i think
i've told cog and solved this before she
had this deal she was a hairdresser
and she would cut this lady at kb toy's
hair for free
and the lady at kb toys would give her a
game just a random game
to take home to me and so uh you know i
got to experience all these games
very fortunate and and and the console
itself just always meant a lot to me
because
it was it was mine first of all and i
didn't have much
uh but i always thought again everything
we said about the arcade is kind of true
it was different from nintendo
right it wasn't as appreciated but it
gave you unique experiences the whole
cartridge and car thing was cool
right at the time as a kid uh the light
phaser was awesome putting the little
joysticks in the uh
in the in the pads right and uh
modular controllers right yeah so just
just everything about the console always
stuck with me and it
you know it just it had a lot a lot of
good and underappreciated experiences on
it that
people look so fondly back on the nes
today as they should right but the sms
never gets any love and it's just a
shame because i don't think anyone
not anyone but a much smaller percentage
of people just
got to experience the games at that time
that they would have really appreciated
i think compared to nintendo
no i agree i agree and it's funny you
say that it's because also
i think it was also understated the
power of that system in comparison was
more powerful than the nes
yes yes what was it this is a z80 c32
yeah it was okay okay yeah yeah yeah
yeah it was it was a beast guys get it
oh mike i'm sorry
i'll just say michael no better than me
no but that and that was the one
that was the one thing that that that
sega always had was
at the time that they were together they
were always the better hardware
yeah and the master system looked better
sounded better better
um it did yeah had notably better sound
yeah and the games had a better sound
board and it just create
again created kind of experiences you
couldn't find on the nes no no stephen
the console first of math system like
what did that mean to you
i mean i have i have a fairly similar
story to ames and that
i remember when my parents got the
system i don't know why i wanted a sega
but i really for some reason wanted it
maybe it was a commercial or something
but
i really really wanted one i remember
when i remember there's a story
i'm canadian so there's a store in
canada it's called consumers
distributors
distributed and you go into it's like
it's like a storefront
on a warehouse and you go in it's like
retail like super cheap stuff you go in
you
you ask for what you want you get a
number someone goes in the back and the
warehouse pulls it out brings it back to
you
and for some reason after i remember
going with my parents
in the car for them to get it and i
remember being convinced they got me
an nes and i was like i was like for all
of december because i got it for
christmas i was like crushed i was so
mad i don't know why i thought this but
i and then when i opened it up on
christmas day i was like just blow it
away i was like this
they actually got me the right thing
this is amazing
so you're good so i was gonna say one
other thing that really stands out for
me it with the
with the master's demis that was the
first time
as a kid i remember you know when you
get a piece of electronics and they put
like that uh plastic
kind of protective layer i remember
distinctly like taking that off the
controller and like the red
kind of stuff i remember that that was
like my first experience with that
and i remember being like so careful
with it it was like such a precious
thing yeah and it just
it looked like a a higher end machine
yeah
yes yes very sophisticated it felt
premium
definitely nintendo always had that toy
feeling where the
stuff did feel like an adult sort of
product
exactly yeah yeah though you have some
history here
oh man i mean for me it was like
my first sort of uh experiences with the
master system were cogs house right
cacog pretty much got it immediately
when it came out and
i guess what it was like holiday 86
is when it came up yeah i just wanted to
interject and say that is super cool you
guys are still friends like that that's
pretty rare to like oh yeah everybody's
going to know each other
because we've been in every class all
the way up all the way almost wow that's
unbelievable super that's part of what
makes
what makes the iron lords work yeah that
that is part of what
it really does it's true yeah the
stories you guys share man are just the
impact the nostalgia right this is like
yeah look my brother my brother's in the
chat
his brother this is my pal from from
from you know we were little kids and
it's like
we've played gi joes and transformers
together like
you know so it's like all these
experiences are shared so
that's what makes them so amazing to me
so i didn't have it yet
cog had it from the beginning and of
course the sega love from the arcades i
was just like oh my god this is amazing
but i also could not ignore
the nintendo zeitgeist that was going on
right so
it was one of those things like man i'm
torn i don't know so
um in my house my parents were very good
about getting us everything that we
asked for
but it was very much a trade-off like we
get you what you want
you're probably not going to get it when
you ask for it but guaranteed christmas
time you probably have it if you've
earned it it was all about earning it
so i got it the following christmas and
the following christmas was also the
time when uh
you know the uh whatever like my my
parents
finally clued me in on the there's no
santa claus thing
the reaction spoilers
um so it like it was the first time that
i felt like i was an adult when my dad
was like all right we're gonna go to the
store and pick out your christmas stuff
and i want you to pick it out i'm like
okay wow
so we go to sears
and they had it shout out to sears and
and they had the nes and they had
the master system and the nes being that
it was so popular
there was no kind of deals with it there
was it was just the nes
i don't think it it was the one that
finally came with mario as a pack-in so
it had like duck hunt and marist it was
the gun
yeah and mario there was no gyro or
anything like that
and then the master system came with the
light gun
it came with the two controllers it came
with hang on safari hunt and this one
also came this one also came with astro
warrior so we had
all those three games out the gate
and then in addition to that there was
something else there was something else
and that was for me cog and i spent
many an afternoon after school playing
double dragon yeah
uh kaibatsu
yeah so our double dragon love was was
unparalleled
and so the deal was hey you're
if you buy this system now you will in
the mail you will receive a
copy of double dragon the one that angel
has right behind him
double dragon for the master system that
perfectly emulates the arcade experience
a two-player game and it's virtually
content-wise identical to the arcade
game can we fanboy the nes one did not
have two players
did not have nes one was a different
game what a fanboy
a whole different game yeah it was a
whole different game it just didn't feel
the same so i said
that moved me because it was it was
touch and go for a minute because again
the nintendo's like guys i'm like damn
mario
yeah and then this kind of put me over
the top and in addition to that so i got
that
i was excited for that i kind of wasn't
sure that i'd receive it i'm like i
don't believe this they're not going to
send me this game or whatever i just got
chased it or whatever
so mind you that game
did not come out until 88
on the master system yup i received my
copy of double dragon
in april of what's
excuse me october 88 it came out right i
got it in
april 88. yeah he had it so
this was i got it in the mail i cannot
believe it i opened it up it was i got
it i think it was on monday or something
like that
and immediately i looked at my mother
and my at my house the rule was no video
games during the week
none she said mom
[Laughter]
and she was like okay you can play for
an hour and that's it
and then for the weekend right so then
the very next day i'm excited i take the
case to school i'm like
you guys will never believe what i have
i didn't believe you i didn't believe
you
oh no because i said it first and i
hadn't pulled the case out i pulled the
case out with the with the instruction
booklet
and cog is like oh my god bro
the white box the blue stripes do you
know the vibes
didn't have those rules and regulations
so he's like i'm going home with you
today i'm like all right fine
at the school baby so i think he's just
coming over to play right i didn't know
what the master plan was right
so he's like we play for a little while
my mother lets us play again right
shout out to mom because this is not
this is not part of the plan right
she lets us play for a little while and
then cog is like
he had mrs anders can i borrow it until
friday and i'll bring it back on friday
he asked my mother not me
it's not my mother my mother loved him
she's like of course barry
[Laughter]
i cannot believe
again and he took it i know he played he
must have played it a million times
during the course of the rest of that
week and then he brought it back to me
friday
and then again that weekend we went and
we played together again
um double dragon was life for us and
that
that really brought me into the master
system fold and then after that
i mean to be honest guys like like ayn
said there are so many underrated
experiences
i got some nope look man like i'm
looking at a list right now cause you
tend to forget stuff but
alex kid govailius like
um rastan fantasy star um
can't cog remember ken sayden
i was gonna say that that was the one
for me because
that was as a kid that game it
represented
i'm gonna say japanese mythology it was
mythology
it was sort of uh it was uh what's
samurai style yeah it was a sam
you were a samurai it was kind of like
the dark souls of his time on a 2d level
and it was about
it mike this was the first game that
truly scared me as a kid like i was
very intimidated by this game like this
game it had very
dark themes and like everything i was
saying was alex kidd hang on
yeah it's just like creating in his
colors evil
demons and i'm like what is it brutally
hard
some of the best music you will ever
hear you know what i mean
and it it also basically you would
travel to different provinces in japan i
believe
and it had backtracking you could it was
very expensive for us
and graphically it looked really amazing
good yeah so i got it i got a shout out
concern i'm gonna let you continue you
saw that okay yeah
yeah real quick so yeah kinsadin uh the
ninja
like to me everything about the class
felt so like the fact that you had
cartridges
and then you had the these hue card
games like i remember playing my hero
card yeah that game was as hard as i
could it was hard
it was tough as hell and then big shot i
gotta give a big shout out to uh
to my brother cause again he's always
been a gaming savant and we got
actually along with the console when we
got it for christmas
we got rambo first blood part two
and as big like akari warriors fans
we're like okay this is this is their
version of that
this game was so difficult that game i
remember that game with my brother that
game was you didn't have like one life
or two lives and you have to start the
whole thing over
all over again
and his just amazing skill we would not
have beaten that game but
the part that steve was talking about is
the is the end of the game
yeah and it's a cityscape and the thing
is these your enemies would throw
bouncing molotov cocktails and grenades
and
you moved perfectly slow enough to not
be able to get out of the way if you
made
a tactical error and turned the wrong
direction it was so
gr it was bad but it was so good
man that the master system was very very
special
to me i wanted to have one story on
consignment
me and my brother my goals by gaming i
had it yeah well you know about the
whole world i love
i love kids it was awesome but we had
this older kid in the neighborhood he
also was a sega guy
and as a young kid you cut well at least
for me you like really respect the older
guys yeah
and he told he convinced me and my
brother greg that there was like a
secret boss
this like green dragon in considering
and
he doesn't exist in the game there is no
secret boss but like that we like played
through it over and over and over
oh my god it's funny that i didn't think
anybody would remember uh can say it was
very you know obscure but it's cool to
see i will fly with the a's i know he's
gonna
get get some bars off but i gotta get my
no mike master wasn't
in your pocket then but like did i ever
go
back to it or was it just completely
from your history was a part of it at
all
it wasn't it wasn't typically part of my
history um
i wasn't really i was still into
pc gaming at the time i was still doing
i hadn't i hadn't really moved
i had a colecovision you know that was
that was my thing back then and then i
kind of moved into the
pc sphere and then it it was genesis
when i got back
got it okay we almost did we always no
no i'm loving this there are some there
are some things that i do
remember okay from from the you know
especially
a lot of the ports that came backward
from the genesis that actually were
yeah almost as good mm-hmm yeah you know
so
and uh aladdin i think too was one that
was just about as good as the genesis
version
yeah no i'm enjoying listening to this
okay cool cool
so like i got it i want to go buy one
right now
we gotta have a havelo segment here um
there was a game
that at the time i didn't know what it
was it had this i don't even know where
you're going with you
i'm about to set you up i'm about to set
you up there was a game i didn't know
what it was cuz
let's be real at that that generates
that error
the box art meant a lot yes
no no no resources to determine for the
most part what was good so the box art
would get you
and there's a game behind ames and i
remember was this woman
and she had a shield and i was like what
is
this game this is for fat boy in the
chat too you know he came prepared
you know we came here i believe this is
a copy that i got when i was 10 years
old this is my original
all right i'm a huge i was huge oh my
god
wow talk about it complete look at that
red and black
the manual and it has a saves on it
right at um dark falls at the end of the
game oh nice
let's talk about it ace what got you
damn it to fantasy star
yeah so yeah there's a few things i'll
talk about master system so so mike you
can cover me on saturday and i'll cover
your master's
all right all right fantasy star so i
was it came out in 88 right
in the u.s at least and i was 10.
and i got it for christmas because it
was an expensive game right it's battery
backup
and you remember um i think on the back
of it it says like four mega remember
which is a big deal
it was a big deal yeah you were like oh
this game whoa
and you could save your progress yeah
what
[Laughter]
so uh i had no idea what it was to your
point you just get a game and you see
characters on the front you get four
screenshots on the back right and you're
like all right what is this
and no instruction manual like i said i
had i had no family members like my
siblings are way older
so i didn't have like brother or sister
that would help and no friends that had
it locally so they didn't know
right so on the nes you had dragon
warrior
and you had fan uh final fantasy and
those became very very big obviously
um on sega master system you had fantasy
star in this game man
like it took me a while to figure it out
and i remember just sitting there around
a
winter vacation as a kid uh when i got
it at christmas and just
you know just going through it because
that's all you did is you only gave my
hat you know what i mean so that was
what you played
and um it just it is
so good from a classic jrpg standpoint
and it brought forth so many concepts
that
were i i believe taken for granted at
the time because
i'll stack up fantasy star against
dragon warrior one
all day long all day long it's not even
a competition in my book
um it's got four different planets you
go to right which you know at the time
was kind of crazy because you literally
do explore them all it had the 3d
obviously the biggest music yeah
and even worse they trick you even worse
because they put traps
hidden walls oh my god
it was insane i remember there was one
like late game right and and you go and
then
you find that you have to find the
stairs remember you go up yeah
multi-level
yes and you know you go up and i'm like
finding my way through
finally like after dying and retrieval
you go up again oh i'm at third level
now right
and i see a door in the distance i'm
like oh my god i made it you know you
walked towards the door and you fell all
the way to the first level
it's a trap i was like oh no
um but again it's just there's so much
to that game and
i honestly i used to i don't have the
time nowadays i used to go back and play
it all the way through about once every
year or two you know what i mean it's
been a long time now but it's just so
special to me
um there there's a funny story real
quick to an anecdote on it there's a
spot in that game if you've played this
game and remember it
all the way through remember there's a
spot where a point in the game where you
have to get a
pass yeah the passage
right yeah doesn't tell you how to do
that you don't have any idea
um so like i just remember being like i
don't know where i'm supposed to go and
what i'm supposed to do and i remember
just take i
and you know you exaggerate things as
you get older so i don't know if it was
weeks or months
but i made no progress on the game yeah
like at all because i didn't know what i
was supposed to do and eventually i
remember finding it and it like a light
bulb went off and i just you know
got so excited that i could continue the
game um
but yeah so special and so we talked
about it already right
so underappreciated like you try to go
back now but when you say fantasy star
people nowadays immediately go to
pso right on right right right um but
fantasy star
one two and four three to a lesser
degree i think we all agree
um they're just really really special
games and i i i wish they kind of had
that uh
you know uh appreciation to them that uh
final fantasy and dragon warrior yeah it
should be in that pantheon i
completely agree shout out to lord metro
he said you should have saved some
macettas remember the best yeah
yeah that that was a big thing and um
yeah i agree completely
that that game changed me as well i
remember the music i remember the
characters
you had odin you had to cat meow and
yeah
it was just so cool and i i again i was
my one of my introductions to jrpgs
i want to transition quickly to steve
because we got to talk about it
you know when i had you on law's [ __ ]
you know where i'm going
yeah it's a game yeah listen i gotta i
got i just got a
chat i just got a chat on xbox live
talking about
have you mentioned this game yet yeah
exactly i know where you're going too i
know
this game changed the way i
fundamentally
play games like like i never played a
game
and and then i had like a notepad next
to me
and it was just it was this game it was
it was called zillion
it was it was a very interesting unique
game now i want to stop start with that
one now the second one
i didn't like we'll talk about the
second one but yeah yeah the second one
was a complete departure from the first
one and they tried the most
disappointing points of yeah yeah
very disappointed
the jump they made was was but it was
just a completely different game but i
wanted i want to pass stephen like
what about zillion that got you i gotta
know
i mean zillion i i think with evolve
with all of us the the games that kind
of hit her just kind of have a story
outside of the game that kind of makes
it more special so that zillion was a
game that
uh my dad randomly brought home one day
and so zillion was also an expensive
game it was more expensive than most of
the games
i think it was good because of the
graphics i don't know why my dad's not a
gamer my dad's like
like he's a baseball player he doesn't
like games at all but he like randomly
went to like
his computer store and brings this game
home mm-hmm zillion i still remember the
cover art and thinking that's like wow
this looks cool
and then my brother and i popped it in
and it as as cogs was saying like
zillion is basically was sega's answer
to metroid yes
but they to me it's much more of a
cerebral game than metroid because you
actually have to like memorize things
every single room you're you're
memorizing like a code
of weird symbols every single room to
get through
[Laughter]
and you really had to pay attention the
whole time and then you also had like
the worst jump
feel horrible it was like
delayed up but then you floated and then
came down so it made it really hard to
get over traffic
yes uh the thing i remember most about
that game
other than those things is they did an
awesome job of teasing
like the characters you could save apple
and champ like that that was amazing
you see a like a apple kind of in
carbonite like han solo style
yes and then you spend like you know an
hour or two hours something like that
try to get to them and then i remember
getting them and then i don't know if
you remember the end cog but oh yeah uh
the end those guys they just basically
like it's like
you you have to escape this thing i
don't i played it many times and i've
always made it out but i wonder if you
don't make it out does the game just end
yeah the planet would explode i mean
that that
part really put terror in me because
they have insane
you basically played the game and it was
just huge underground maze for the most
part
with all these different terminals and
you had to memorize all these levels
that you had to save your compadre and
stuff but
like you said you get to the boss you
get to the end
and then it's a self-destruct sequence
with a
big timer while you're fighting the boss
on the way out yeah so it's crazy added
as a kid it added so much
tension like what's gonna happen now
granted probably was now you look back
at it was probably more than enough time
right in our my mind my childhood mind
it was the fear of god and stress to get
out of this place
but continue continue stephen that was a
game that i couldn't play
i watched cog play that game i could not
play that game yeah
do you call do you remember the red
cards yeah blue cards and you get the
four
those there was just a color change but
that was like those were the four
coolest cards i've ever heard
man no i just love that game it is like
still i've gone back and played it many
times
um i think it's just it's really like
was the reason i wanted to make video
games that game
um fine i also that that and fantasy
star were my two favorite games
nice genesis for sure i don't know if
you guys remember the last maze in
fantasy star was all
gold yes like and a secret like
yeah and if anyone say like i must have
played through that maze
i don't know weeks the thing is like in
modern game design you put landmarks in
a maze
it's just it's literally gold bricks
that's it it's just a gold one
mike it was brutal forever it is so hard
i had notepads where i tried to draw
lines
trying to draw the grass and stuff yeah
and you know every step you took was a
chunk right it was like chunk chunk so i
literally started going one click
two clicks three clicks all right make a
left one click
it was so hard wow i have a funny story
about zillion two
uh which wasn't as good but the last
boss on zillion two
is the hardest boss i've ever played yes
yes uh i was there
my brother was like when i was facing
that pause i was there my brother was
there
but our two friends across the street
who are nintendo guys and that's kind of
like my childhood
they were there i i died to this boss
like 20 times
i kicked all of them out of the room i
needed like complete silence
and i finally beat them but i turned
around and they were like peeking
through the door
watching
real quick shout out to the uh chat look
kai little known fact zillion was based
on an anime i found that out later
i don't know i didn't know that yeah i
never knew it was it apparently it was a
popular anime for forbes i can see that
that makes sense actually all the art
and stuff was really
the character art and all the like that
was beautiful now this might mike might
help me out here because
i believe the people who did that art
the production company
it's a tatsunoko is the people did
gotcha
that was one of their first so the
geforce cartoon and all that stuff
that's from knows that from from that so
that was pretty amazing to me and then a
real quick side note
shout out to um fat boy heart he's like
any gold alias love before yeah
yes no doubt
no doubt but yeah i mean i'll finish up
with my system
pretty much you guys said all of them
you know those are the ones for me the
the car games i had the my heroes and
all that stuff
and another thing that we forget about
is the uh the 3d glasses
actually oh my god they pioneered that's
3-d
yes and everyone i've talked to said it
really does work
yes yes very very impressive
yeah just it was just it was a very it
was a very ambitious system very
powerful and like and said it best it
just
it just looks so sophisticated it's just
sorry sorry sorry i was going to say
don't forget too that the uh the light
phaser they had some
really strong games for that yeah like
gangster town i always
yeah yeah oh yeah
it was like you know they always had a
response to nintendo that's our hogan's
alley
yeah response but the light phaser also
had like rainbow three
and they had rescue mission they had
operation wolf which was uh
yes you know i mean from the arcade so
uh light phaser gains are great
and then the only other thing that
popped in my head is you guys were
talking about double dragging because we
were joking about that being far
superior to nintendo absolutely don't
forget ghostbusters was the same way
yeah yeah that's right amazing
shout out to greg miller that was his
that was the introduction
ghostbusters was amazing for that it was
way better than that it's for the
hardcore
system that that special feature
would not be
yeah it was this maze thing unlocked it
i just thought it was the coolest thing
man but yeah salute to that the cards
the
the system and then like i said they
they even though we knew the difference
between the arcade
at least they had the hang-ons the
outruns you still but they did attempt
to make conversions of it and i believe
what was that hang on was the packet
right hang on in
hanging on safari hunt yeah and then
they had they had an astro warrior pack
in at at one point
and obviously uh alex kidd won as well
yeah yeah he mixed it up as time went on
yeah absolutely yeah it did you know
support just
to say as we get into this next
generation which we'll move on to is i
want to know
there's two more sega i want to see if
any of you guys have played it so one
was rocky did anyone play them
yes my god i love that game so i got to
stop you
right now i played i played that i
played that in sears by the way i did
play it but i had to go to sears to play
it bro there are a few we haven't
mentioned that we're like real yeah
there's quite a few actions
but thank you steve uh yo that was one
of the best rocket games
yeah okay i thought it i thought it
looked beautiful
phenomenal i could never beat clubber
lange because the tree
so rocky was this game where you had
three fights right and you had to fight
and then you trained
you changed and how well you trained the
better how you did
how fast you were in the next fight yes
and so i could never train fast enough
to be
clubber lane was the one with the with
the bits was that the yeah
yes one guy was mitch one guy was speed
bag
whoever was this oh okay so it was true
it was drago i could never beat i could
not go
okay was like the tyson of that game
yeah so i i was a kid i could never do
it and then one day i i had a pop can
sitting by my uh my thing i took a pop
can
and i would rub it on the buttons so the
buttons would get like
insane beyond human speed inputs
and you'd rub it and then you got you
could do the speed bag like blow the
meter right back and then you could
destroy drago no problem at all
yes bro i gotta shout you how in the
hell did i forget rocky right
rocky bike let me tell you man this
thing graphically yeah
oh it was it was oh my god yeah bro like
i remember seeing the
the character models and just with
mickey training with you
and there's nothing like it yeah it was
like really good you know and um you can
see the music
was good that clubberland got me to like
you had to be
ve depending on the score you got on the
successful that training
was how well your rocky did in the fight
and yeah draggle as well you know yeah
that was a phenomenon what was your
second one you're about to say another
you said rocky yeah the other one was a
small
game called i never i've never known how
to pronounce it it was y
s east it was easy okay so it's like a
role-playing game
you you didn't even have an attack
animation you'd literally just run into
guys
but i like it you could do like a lot of
like um
um like you could break kind of the the
mold like you could go
into the mines and get this like silver
shield way early and then make other
things easy
uh that game like was super cool because
you could do all the kind of neat things
it did have a bug where if you got to
the one you guys remember the room where
you go in there and your life would just
drain
the sky was i don't know something you
could get stuck in that room
you didn't have a certain item and
you'll have to restart the whole game so
i i played that kind of thing
yeah i was always impressed that a game
like that came to the master system
yes i mean yeah and that by the way was
a yuzo kashiro
uh he helped with that soundtrack nice
that that was back then what you didn't
have like they didn't
have those mental barriers about now
this game wouldn't work here it's just
like
let's do it let's figure it out let's do
it
and see what happens man yeah i mean
they had ultima on there
yes ultimate ultimate four wow i
remember that i mean that was a little
bit
for my age i was like i can't really get
down with this but
it was just impressive to have it there
but the a few that we didn't mention
there are especially missed ones
for us [ __ ] you know again ninjas kung
fu karate
the ninja that's what
as well um shoplifter
yes oh man
that was also a big occasion
nice shoplifter what a great game and
alien syndrome
black belt was a response to kung fu
yeah exactly
same thing right yeah black belt was
better i'm sorry like black oh yeah
because it was i found out it was
literally
a port of the um it was based on
officially also that's who he was
i never do that until later yes if you
if you remember cause black belt wasn't
i mean black belt wasn't the one on one
like i remember you had to go through a
statement you have to go through a
spanish
actually yeah yeah the boss at the end
yeah right it felt
more like it was fish to the north star
and obviously we got we got last battle
the next generation right
yeah but oh yeah for sure definitely
that chop lift i forgot all that oh man
wow a lot of time
oh that was awesome i want to say on the
ninja that was the first time
me and my brother and our other friend
casey wrote like a game design document
because we played that ninja and then we
like spent all like summer like
writing a game design document on how to
make the ninja better
i wish i still had it because it's
probably just totally gibberish
oh my god the first time i ever did like
any game design yeah i remember that
game vividly he had the disappearing
it would go up right you would yes go up
and then you throw the stars whatever
and i remember that game frustrated me
real quickly and we move on
the um it frustrated me because you got
to like
the board before the end right and the
game
tries to give you a riddle randomly like
it gives you a scroll
and it's like hit the third totem pole
on this day
or this time and i didn't understand
what the hell i remember like
looking at it years later and seeing
someone figure out i was like i've never
finished that game but
yeah that that was one of those moments
it gave design it was very interesting
choice
about them to do that but we got we got
to move on because we could stay on
masses
so we could do this for each system
right we're going to remember in games
i know we go you got it's going to go
but um so if you want to get a couple
super chats before you get it yeah we're
only having
yeah first off general mac five dollars
in a chat
thank you lord sovereign for correcting
my double word in my super chat you are
the best oh hell the iop of course sir
anytime then we have fat boy horror five
pounds
master system needs no defense not even
for his version of shinobi fantasy star
was ahead of its time with a multi-world
rpg and a female protagonist
yeah that's a good point yeah good very
true that time yes
very true then we have gerald back again
five dollars for chat oh hell the iop
aims i saw your game room video
effing awesome yes that is something to
behold
i told him in the name that's like two
years old now i gotta do an updated one
nice we got gerald back again five
dollar super chat
all hell the iop y'all young men making
me proud i'm
50 51 on monday happy birthday to you
sir don't worry i'm
right behind you right behind you
exactly
ain't that far behind i'll tell you i'll
tell you
what call it be young it feels good
what else we got here we have big cloud
gaming five dollars absolute
family thank you sir absolutely well
salute to you brother
then we got heated heavy 505 10 super
chat
got to get back to work but when you
talk genesis games can you talk about
shadow running
i love that yeah baby we're right there
right over here right there
is that the last one yeah perfect
transition so uh
the year is 1989.
um and something mega happens
of a set stick up there was this console
that came
out right right on this side
and uh it was a revolution it was a
revolution for its time
very aggressively marketed very powerful
you know some extreme standouts but i
got to start romance thing like
this was sega for you this brought you
back to the fold so
tell me bro i told and i've told this
story before now i'm 17 years old
and now i'm still you know i'm still at
home you know
my dad at the time was working for a toy
store
uh it's still it's like the back end of
him working on toy store and i'm like
dad you know
i still want to get it i want to get an
nes i see everybody else playing nes
he brought home a genesis and i'm like
what
what this is
not what i asked for i wanted it because
i wanted you know what everybody else
was playing
and this was the one that came with hey
bud
this is the one that came with um
altered b so that was the original
eyes from your grave and i'm like all
right you know my dad's like you know i
brought it home
play it all right so i i get
get it plugged up as soon as i start
altered beats and i've never played
i played golden axe in the arcade
but i had never played altered beast for
whatever reason i can't remember if it
was just
never there or same same thing
but and i knew sega from the arcades but
it was a genus it was like this it
wasn't nintendo this wasn't
you know it was like what did they you
know i'd long since stopped going to the
arcades
for those older games i was going for
newer stuff
so turned on the turned on started the
game
and the just the rise from your grave
and i was like
and the care and and your character you
know
mario's like this big your character is
like huge
talk about those sprites oh my god and
just the the action and all the stuff
going on like
my jaw was just like i was just power up
when he turned it and then when he
turned into the wolf oh my god
so i from that moment on
denounced anything
that was it it was all sega all the time
it was
i mean i had the original set of games
that i got were
pat riley basketball tommy lasorda
basically baseball
good game scaling baseball mania
tasmania which was which at the time no
one had
done anything animation was crazy yeah
and there was this
this little known game called decap
attack
yeah that was and that just hooked me up
and just from then on that is where
i spent every i like for
i transitioned out of pc gaming for that
like i was playing
doom and quake and all this and i just i
left all that to become a sega guy
and that is that it the rest is
history oh my god
let's get to it but who won't jump in
next on this that that system that mega
system
i got a i got a kind of goofy story i
can share uh i know i think i've told
you guys this before at least sullivan
cog maybe but
so big second master system right
genesis
comes out it came out like a couple
months before the holidays in 89 in the
u.s right
and uh really wanted one of course right
um i had played altered beasts and i was
like oh my god arcade graphics you know
what i mean like i was hyped and kb toys
looking over the counter dreamin
and so um no joke right uh it's like
maybe
late november thanksgiving whatever
first week of december and um my mom was
a hairdresser she worked late she worked
all the time
and my friends would come over and hang
out at my house when we played master
system um
and i was like let me snoop around for
christmas presents and i started doing
that as a kid
alan in the closet the genesis oh that
she had it from that lady at kb
i mentioned earlier right and uh i got
like ridiculously excited and to cut
this a long story short right
one night i got real uh you know i
did kind of a dumb thing as a kid but
you do things as a kid
and i i was like i can't wait i can't
wait i just can't wait so i literally
uh
wow me and my friends like she was
working till like 8 p.m i still haven't
told her this
i'm 43 years old um
he hooked it up wait was it wrapped and
packaged it no no no it was the box oh
just
okay so you just okay you okay yeah oh
dude i was like
all right time to do surgery yeah
so we hook it up we start playing play
altered beast and it had ghouls and
ghosts
all in there too which was my favorite
so good right oh my god talk dark souls
let's talk about that
right super hard game continue so anyway
we did that for a few weeks right
and eventually we kept playing altar
beast and i'm like i want to play ghouls
and ghosts but it's
sealed you know what i mean i was like i
wonder if she should notice
the professionals
so he had a head open too yeah he had a
shrink wrap machine in his head
so for a couple weeks we played all
three beasts and goals it goes before
christmas christmas morning comes right
it's wrapped everything
and i was like i wonder what this is i
wonder what this is going to happen
open it up you know fake surprise
my mom my mom's kind of you know she
she's a sweetheart um
uh but she's you know she's not paying
attention to details right so
um hook it up and like that night i
remember again running through ghouls
and ghosts
um because i just love that guy i ran
through it she's like you beat that
already she was all disappointed
and i was like yeah i guess it's just
pretty easy
32 other times so but um
but genesis was and people remember
right in the us genesis came out over
two years before
super nintendo did yeah it did so
genesis was such a much more as mike
said a much more advanced experience
than the nes which was still kind of
raging
and there's so many different things i
know we're going to touch on that
genesis is just my other jam oh eight
and 16 bit errors for me with sega
are like king yes um as much as we'll
get to the others but yeah
so i'll i won't take a lot of time yeah
i've got plenty more i could share i'm
curious on stephen with this i'm very
curious
what genesis with you for some reason
i'm very intrigued i want to know
where you were at that point in your
life and did you get it around launch
did you get it later did you not get it
like where
where were you at with genesis dropped
uh so i
i'm like i'm like you guys a lot in that
sega
and the masters and genesis were like my
two big sega systems so
when we got genesis similar experience
to like altered beasts like blue or mind
it was like
graphically like just incredible the
thing that stands out for me about
genesis is that it really introduced me
to sports
video games yeah because like like
lakers versus celtics
i don't know that game like blew my mind
like
i thought the graphics on that were
amazing that drip head ball handling and
stuff
and then i was a canadian kid like nhl
hockey yes
before before nhl hockey and like for
celtics games were like wayne gretzky
hockey which
had like some approximation of like pro
players but they were really is like
you know bob gretzky or something like
that
yeah when nhl came out had real players
like real
players had real skills yes right like
they actually had different stats
that like i i did that just like totally
like nhl 94 the blood
yeah yeah i said i still remember the
movie swingers where this was
it yeah yeah
the players association one but not the
nlp yeah right but the
94 really was like the perfect because
it was the perfect match you had the
teams the players
and the true story i tell this story all
the time my game history like
no one can tell me about gaming because
i never
listen we solved for this outbreak there
was no hockey going on
yeah when that get
the ea sports game ea sports whatever
easn
right yellow yellow was awesome about
that yeah yellow tab
a sport yellow tab
on the cartridge they were shaped
different yep and the thing
about it it was just like it was so
transformative and it
made it was they were so well done they
made me get interest
in the sport of hockey that's how i fund
those games
i learned what a one time award i went
to my first hockey oh that's because of
nhl
i didn't know anything about the sport
i'd love it shout out i became a
bandwagon pittsburgh
segways i know because i know i know we
had that debate
but in my childhood mine i would that
number
66 was unstoppable before he was
you don't think like that team that they
had was another but i would give it back
to
you
continue your story continues no no that
was really like
those like really transformed like
gaming for me the other one that really
stands out in genesis is flashback
which oh yes under the end is kind of
inspired by actually
movement really yeah yeah so uh yeah
like flashback
that was like to me was i and these are
subtle things like you could actually
take a rock and throw it and then the
guard would like turn around and look at
the rock
and then you could like shoot them and
everything was so deliberate but it
wasn't as deliberate like as prince of
persia was a little more fluid
which was cool and like yeah
like incredible amount of work and pixel
wise was beautiful animation is
beautiful
no hand holding at all just like play
the game no figure out how to do you
didn't even
i don't even think there was a there
wasn't even a opening cut scene it just
dropped you in the game and said you're
just playing this thing
and totally unconventional control it
was like mario where they just jump and
run
yeah you had to like sprint and then
like put hold the a button and then you
launched grab on the legend it was nuts
remembered
that was the sequel that of this world
that did that started that yeah
talk to me talk to me mike you know how
i feel about that
i know yeah that's how i said it i i i
literally
fanboyed out i met eric shaw here in
real life that that man
changed my life like that game you know
what is it baxter robot
like that game changed my life like
that's
why i found you stephen
i told i wrote you a a like i wrote this
man a bible when i found out that
i was like look i don't know what
happened to your game but i'm looking
for it
um this game reminds me of a childhood
favorite and it was another world
it was again that atmospheric
storytelling the game doesn't tell you
what's going on
and that those are kind of the vibes
until the end gave me and i was just
like yo i i've missed
when games were like that so by mike's
point yeah another world was
oh my god that was and it was made by
one
person that's crazy but continue yeah an
interesting story about that
like another world so actually the the
uh character and under the end is in the
side his hair is red because of another
world we're out of this world something
called but
he eric actually made that game one room
at a time like he had no idea where the
game was going to go i watched him do a
design talk once
he would like design a room and get it
to like the way he wanted and then he
would do the next thing
and that's actually why the the story is
quite organic
yes like it doesn't it kind of like goes
all the way all over the place yeah and
it because
that's kind of how he uh he did it i
wanted to see if
cog you you you and salva played this
one buddha khan
he got stories it
funny quick story you know at that time
you know like your kids
money is finances are not there sure
you're all
all you guys have consoles so the plan
was we all got to get okay
you're going to get i'm going to get
revenge shinobi
we're going to get into that but you
know um you know this one's going to get
space harry it is you know you split up
so everyone could trade amongst each
other that was the thing you trade games
with your friend
your stuff like that and we told one of
our friends
to get something i think what what other
gays and both of them come back with
budacon
oh man and we were like why
you don't say but to its credit it was
actually not that bad
it was very difficult very difficult
super difficult yeah yeah
very but compete it was of the sport
fade the competitive margin
the bow they had fencing yeah yeah yeah
but yeah
and at the time at the time they were
doing those multiplayer games like kings
of the beach and stuff like that
and so that fit their mold for that
uh and it was in those in that box like
uh
the the boxes to your over your left
shoulder yes it was ea
those were tight boxes yeah they were
of course about them right i mean this
sounds really stupid i realized but like
that they actually had like a different
film on them yeah and they had different
cover art yeah and as you already
pointed out they had the awesome
yellow man they're just special
and uh i think what was really cool
about these not to take us on a tangent
right but the reason i put these out
among all the games i have is that the
the nintendo side you know that we
talked about it i found a fantasy dragon
warrior and that kind of extended in
especially with the snes era and final
fantasy right
but genesis had these really unique
uh western rpg experiences like the the
ones above there king's bounty is
i put so many hours into that game um
but they just it had like populist
remember populace
yeah the god game like you would have
yeah peter molyneux
yes again had
all these kind of unique experiences and
that that felt like um
you can't get those anywhere else
outside of pc at the time
um but it yeah man it's just god i could
go on forever oh
like solve i'll give it to y'all because
when i go i'm going to take twitter
what's up genesis genesis is special to
me because
i got it i didn't get it when it
launched i got it the following summer
um and it was the first console that i
purchased for myself
um so i was like what i was like 13 14.
and uh i was lucky in that when i worked
summers
i worked at my dad's company and they
would pay me 250
a week right so for a 13 year old kid
that's a lot that's a lot of money
making a thousand dollars a month
oh my god because again all of my
friends
yeah all my friends including cog right
got stuck working what we call
summer you summer youth right and summer
youth
i don't think you even made 200 every
two weeks or something like that it was
something like that
maybe yeah you maybe made 500 a month so
i was
rolling it i was so happy but so i was
super excited to buy it for myself said
dad i'm going to get this for myself
okay fine no problem so i remember the
friday i got paid i'm like
this is the day i'm going to buy it i
told my boss and everything look i'm
going to buy the sega genesis you're so
excited for me so you want me to
you want me to call for like a different
pricing for you i'm like sure so he's
like
he calls the wiz nobody beats the wiz he
calls them all the wiz
and he's like um yeah so uh when you say
nobody beats the wiz you mean that
literally
like well um yeah i mean we'll pre we'll
price match but it has to be like a
store that's equal in stature to us
yeah you know
oh yeah yeah yeah whatever so again i
went to the whiz
and that it was essentially my entire
check right because it's
i didn't understand the concept of tax
at that time i thought
that was what was there how much 199 it
was like 199 it was a 200
console right yeah so it was 200 bucks
and then
with the tax and everything that was my
check so
i was short on my transportation money
for the following week so i look at my
dad
and back then it was it was tokens it
was train tokens yes
yes so he's like all right i'll buy your
bag of tokens for next week but you got
to pay me at the end of next week i'm
like fine no problem
so we go we pick up our sega genesis i'm
so happy
and on fridays in the summer time at
that job
we got out early so it was one o'clock
so we left early
you know we we were back in the bronx by
like two o'clock i had my system and
everything
so my dad's like yeah um i'm gonna go
hang out with the with the with the boys
over
at the at the garage right his friends
at the garage
so i'm just gonna stop there for a
little bit um mind you the garage is
maybe
i don't know five blocks away from my
house but i was not gonna go by myself
with my console so i had to stay with my
dad
i don't know so 20 minutes turned into
like
four hours oh man and i'm sitting there
my i'm looking through the far window
through the car window looking at my
console that i can't play
and my dad and i'm like i'm looking at
my dad like you know what you're doing
to me
it's torturing me so i finally get it
home let's go i had
um i had uh whatchamacallit uh altered
beast
and altered beast despite not being the
greatest game ever but
it was it a graphical launch game
for a launch game that's supposed to
show you what the console can do it it
was perfect yeah two players
yes exactly so myself and kaibatsu got
carboxyl got in there
and we were having loads of fun so we
didn't get our next
sort of set of games until a little bit
afterwards um
and i just remember the first ones being
shout out to you guys for what you said
about the sports it really did bring me
into like the sports gaming genre i've
always loved baseball i played baseball
my entire life
i i forgot to mention great baseball and
reggie jackson baseball on the masters
reggie jackson man yeah jackson which i
love you should go in you know and
fight the yeah i was i was jealous of
bases loaded for the fight but but i
love the the master system
games um and obviously world series
baseball on the general show is huge for
me
and like getting getting to play
tomorrow's order and stuff early on i
love it
tommy lasorda was so good it was so
so good it was so good but that was one
of the few games i rented multiple times
with
a single weekend rental i would get a
blockbuster
exactly like to the mom and pop rental
shop
or the the supermarket you could rank
games yeah
exactly but but the one that was
transformative for me in terms of sports
games
was joe montana sports oh yeah
sports talk oh my
it just that game and the fact
that when you when you made a great play
it would
zoom in and scale inward i'm like how is
this doing this
possible to me that was peak graphics at
that point i think the consistent thing
that we're saying
a lot with genesis yeah is the big
sprites yeah yeah you're right right if
you really look because
i mean just cutting you that was another
reason why i'm like why did i like
last battle so much like right game
wasn't good
young me and that again it was you know
you power up
jack got jacked and then you know he's
doing it it was the speed of the game
and the sprites they were so
large and we're coming from mass system
and yes and you're used to these little
rinky-dink kind of characters
and then you're seeing these almost full
screen
beasts of sprites but continue yourself
i just had to mention that i was trying
to
figure it out i think that that's so
true because again it was the first time
that you really
the thing that you had in your house yes
was at least somewhat
close to the arcade it was like oh my
god we're there
right we weren't quite there but in your
mind you're there
and you know you're playing golden axe
and you're playing um
contra and stuff like that and it's just
like man uh
that that console for me it really kind
of opened up my eyes to
a bunch of different types of games in
the same way the master system did
because again
like we like we talked about the master
system wasn't afraid to put on gate put
games on there that maybe didn't belong
there right
um yeah and i think the same was true of
the genesis the genesis
it took a lot of risks on these consoles
not knowing what would sell or not
obviously there was a lot of
side-scrolling games action games but
you got
a lot of weird stuff like herzog's wii
and like
rts games and stuff with that nature i
was going to mention herzog you beat me
to it no no but
i'll let you i'll let you go in in depth
on that one but for me the stuff that
really stuck out was
was the side scrolling stuff right and
i you know i was a little bit older at
this time and i'm
i'm kind of moving away from the kiddie
games but
one that brought me back wholeheartedly
that i could not deny the quality of
which one was castle of allu evolution
mouse beautiful game one of the most
beautiful to this
day one of the most beautiful games i've
ever played
an amazing side-scrolling experience at
you know a
platform experience absolutely blew me
away
and then again talking about all the
other stuff that like you know
the arcade sort of conversions the the
golden axe
uh playing stuff like ninja turtles and
things of that nature
um real finished turtles exactly the
real ninja turtles
thing um yeah it was man there was just
so much on that console that just kind
of blew me away
um when you talk about the rpgs uh
you know you we we the people that
played the original fantasy star
and you play fantasy stars
yes i have it go grab it what what was
it called um
[Music]
which one which one which one gravity
gravity i'm gonna go get it i'll be
right back
all right because there was so many what
was that well he's doing that
let me ask you a question yeah so since
you were a big baseball guy
and we talked you just talked about joe
montana what was it like because i
remember what i was like
with that first time baseball sports
talk baseball
oh i i was i was an assassin with the
texas rangers right
uh uh we had like julio franco raphael
palmeiro
um juan gonzalez um kevin reimer
like wow we're taking it these do like
i love that game so much and it was it
was so
good all of those games were so
amazingly good can we just and it was
like how
how did they get the commentary so wow
can we just admit that like i think both
of you touched on it stephen touched on
it
ainsley would definitely agree like they
were the de facto sports kings
yes i wish
bill was here because if bill bill would
be like we had him on ilp we're doing
his history
and he he's talking about being on army
base with a genesis
and you know the nhl the lakers versus
celtics the
you know what i'm saying like the the
madden that's madden y'all
all the sports like even as good as
rocky was on the master system
buster douglass
right these guys really were almost as
big as the actual
yeah yeah the actual boxers mike buster
douglas the one you could make your own
boxer and you could make like a
green i'm like yourself goodbye and then
like i can't master douglas you'd like
fight all the way through and then you'd
get the title but your guy
actually aged yeah he actually ate yes i
remember
he's right you're right and you had to
keep defending and defending yourself
get
older and older and slower like that was
such a cool idea
boxing games are good i mean greatest
heavy waves greatest heavier which is
amazing
great do you guys remember
um these were a little more obscure but
i know that i remember cog remembers
because we
you know we would sometimes we'd go
purchase games
and we look for the obscure ones like
the ones that not everybody went after
which one it was one called midnight
resistance
that was so much for that one yeah very
good and then
um the other one was what the heck is it
oh
a mystic mystic defender
i'm sorry no bro again early launch
title i would say
yeah still very early games yeah and
again we talked about the sprites but
the thing about that game that was crazy
because he had the magical powers like
they would extend on the character and
he would have fired
it was a very dark game too it's kind of
it was it was a
very important sequel it's a sequel to a
master system game
i never knew that yes i forgot the name
of the original game but yes
okay yeah mystic defender absolutely
yeah
that's great i'll jump in real quick
i'll give it then i'll give this thing
um
we'd be remiss if we didn't talk about
streets of rage oh
look this is the days and you know
final fight ruled in the arcade if i
remember yeah it did it
was absolutely two-player again the
thing about jen is we talked about the
sports we talked about the sprites
but as we alluded with mad sister with
double dragon
with the two-player co-op genesis was
able to
bring a two-player beat him up with
graphical fidelity
and some of the most amazing music we've
ever heard sting right
oh my god but before we do that can we
talk
i mean you touched on something can we
talk about how
good how good the sound chip in the
genesis was yeah and i i remember the
first game that
really which one so it did it for me and
michael jackson's moonwalk the fact that
it was like i played that game just to
listen to the soundtrack
yeah just because it was so close
and and and so different from the arcade
the arcade was a whole different
game than the genesis yes it was yes but
but the soundtrack was so amazing and
michael jackson
i mean he was a sega fan with he worked
with sega
on that game to do that i mean but those
and and and somebody mentioned it in the
chat sword of vermillion
million oh my goodness the opening
i would just let the opening the dragon
just run because it it hit you with this
and a bolt of thunder
and then it went into this then it went
into the the building
and i was like oh my god
on the back of my neck goosebumps
brother
bro like they they had a lot of rpgs
yeah i remember was correct me if i'm
wrong with sort of a
did wasn't it a double perspective game
was it like a
one of them games i thought was maybe
i'm mixing up my games i thought
you might be thinking um
and then it had another part of it but
maybe i could be confused yeah i don't
remember but oh by the way mike here's
the
dnd game it's warriors of the eternal
there it is where is it
oh yeah yeah that was a great game yeah
i actually picked that up recently no
joke like
just recollected stuff yeah um but you
know i got to touch on fantasy star too
please yeah let's get out get to it so
so another true story i uh you know
fancy star one we talked about right
we're going into what was that store in
the malls that
specialized in uh movies like
sunday coast what suncoast suncoast
that's it
that's it so we were walking through the
mall me and my mom again a couple after
genesis
came out right and walking to suncoast
you remember they started selling games
for a short period of time
and i walk in there and you joked about
it earlier called back then you didn't
know what was going on
games just appeared in stores and you're
like alright what's that
so i saw a fantasy star too and
immediately i was like
oh my god oh my god they made another
one
and it was it was what was it ninety
dollars it was super expensive yeah
yeah and it came it came with the big
hint book hitbox sealed in it
six mega cartridge yeah yeah that was a
big deal
in my hands and i saw the price and all
my mind was like i know i can't get this
but you're gonna get this super
expensive and my mom ended up again got
it for christmas
that year and i just remember um you
know going through that game that is an
epic epic game um
and a great follow-up to the first one
so that's one of my just all-time
favorites
um very hard bosses at the end remember
the mother brain dark motherboard
yeah yes but i think it's just hard in
general yeah yeah
super hard to get through some of those
things
when they died when they
[Music]
messed me up they
no no you're fine the other the other
thing uh there's so many games we can
talk about jessica
genesis went on for years you know such
a long run um
and i know mike can touch on sega cd and
all those things better than i can um
but going back to nhl real quick let's
go um
nhl was like life-changing because i
played hockey i still do
um and as a hockey player like steven
said
it's just completely different than
anything that had come before right
and at the time when i got into like nhl
94 95
i was on a ice hockey team that traveled
and we used to take a bus
to up the up the northeast like boston
we'd go to canada sometimes
so and we'd play and on the bus we'd
usually have like one tv and we figured
out on our team how to hook up a genesis
this weekend we also got an nhl
tournament we got to settle and we would
have
a bracket of tournament of nhl that
we've watched awesome
i love that every uh every time we would
travel and so just great memories with
those games man
bro the competitive i think because of
that like it brought out the competitive
scene the
aspect in a lot of gamers you know
saying because this is you know the
couch co-op i mean the couch next to
each other competitive days
very you know thing i want to be remiss
if we didn't forget
before we get i'm gonna get into my
games but i think um sting will
appreciate this
is that genesis also was special to me
because
again at the time you know if new
console came out
you had to leave the stuff behind yeah
but there was this thing
called the power converter
and as a master system fan who didn't
get rid of it
and had all these great games you
plunked that
big contraption on top of your genesis
it had the little lid
remember and you put your red and black
sega masters in games
so back with compatibility i don't don't
quote me from wrong i won't say it
debuted
i don't know if they were the first but
i remember it being a big deal
to me that i could still play my master
system games
on genesis my i think even the card
games they had cards worked
you're right there wasn't much i mean
that you can't really count the
colecovision because the expansion port
on the colecovision plate atari 2600
carts
right so you really couldn't count that
the genesis really was the
one of the first that truly had yes a
backward compatible to its
to its predecessors to its predecessor
like i've never seen that at the time i
thought that was so cool
we talked about sports and i know again
this is still we're before
broadband at that time but i don't know
if you guys remember x-band
yeah and x-band was a huge deal for me
because again like when the nba lives
came out and that stuff
you know provided mom wasn't using the
phone while you were playing
because you had to put your little your
phone jack in your 4 your 336 phone
whatever you had going on
and you could play it was they they had
their own online infrastructure
and you could play it through genesis
and that was a big deal you know for us
sega channel
the sega chat yeah that's pretty cool i
didn't know about any of this yeah
yeah the second channel was i mean
literally that was
sega pushing the boundaries of
distributing games digitally yes wow
that's cool
yeah yeah i mean was it in the
neighborhood or was that only in
the states you think i don't know i'm
not sure yeah because i never heard
about any of that at all that's
interesting
yeah you could subscribe and literally
there was a selection of games i mean
it's like
it's crazy right when you think about it
now 30 years ago but
it was getting games to people digitally
yes wow that is that is unbelievable
yeah and again for me coming off again
now the games wise again coming off my
system i already told you everything
there with the learning
genesis closed the gap you know so as
far as the arcade stuff i remember to
get in the super hang on and be like
okay this
is really close you know what i'm saying
i i gotta talk about revenge and shinobi
[Music]
bro like this is usual in his bag i
remember the opening screen the music
the cinema the thunder it blocks this
thing
and like they were breaking all type of
rules they had batman and
terminator likenesses and it's spiderman
like they were breaking all
sega was very aggressive and then they
were that thing
could be and they're aggressive the
commercials y'all like
th this was an error but sega does what
nintendo like this is whatever they
would put the competition in their
commercial
and disparage them yeah
like that was really like you don't hear
of that i don't even know legally if you
could do that now like
could like xbox put a playstation you
know in there
you may know their ceo's name but i mean
he was tasked with
in north america right making genesis
the place to play
and taking collectivity
yeah and let me tell you it you know
we're celebrating but
but tom kalinski leaving sega
because of sega of japan was what
started that
that the downward spiral yeah
that man that man that man was an
absolute
ruthless genius oh yeah i mean he he
knew exactly what to do
how to do it and he was responsible for
bringing
i mean think about it at the time the
nintendo entertainment system
was had the corner had the market
cornered because they were strong-arming
third parties
into only and that's why the sega master
system did not
fare well because they couldn't get
third parties to make stuff
for them good point the genesis changed
all of that i agree and that that's why
you see as much multi-platform stuff as
you do today yeah
sega did so much that that
revolutionized the
the game industry over and over and over
again
yeah absolutely absolutely and then um
you know for me
some other little obscure ones this one
i know if you all remember
i don't know soft maybe but this was a
very squish because at the time
graphical fidelity was like okay not
like like um
what you call insect with fantasy star
the six mega cartridge then we got into
the
eight megacorps we sure did oh
huge deal very close to arcade
movement too in stryder was fantastic
like the acrobatics and stuff you can do
is pretty
[Music]
like that was crazy um the only thing
the only thing annoying me about strider
is
it got real hyped up remember yeah yeah
yeah super hyped up yeah
yeah and i got it amazing game right i
beat it the first time
yeah yeah yeah i threw king out my house
he beat them
on the first day i was very upset i was
not happy with him
i bought it the first day he beat it in
my face
obscure one though solved see if you
remember this one we're forgetting
they also were good with with the space
shooters
oh yeah oh come on now i know y'all know
about the techno forces right remember
the techno forces
thunder force thunder force wonderful
right three right
there was an obscure one that i loved it
was so hard but it looked so good it was
called
gay res guys gyrus cyrus
eight meg and what was so unique about
it steven right
i've never seen the game do this most
shooters
you know you shoot the enemies you get
they drop something or something or
whatever
this game you had like a satellite thing
and you would
send it at the enemy to attach and you
would take the enemy's ability
and you could even do it against bosses
i thought it was
it was very very cool yeah very nice
revolution the bosses were very big very
graphically beautiful game
but yeah that guy rest joint crazy and
r-type
oh i thought you're going to say
airtight yeah visually was
insane like i thought that was like i
mean there's still i literally bought
r-type final two for xbox like two
months ago they're still yeah i forgot
about that
and last plus one i got was um on the
races
i used to like the super monaco series i
used to oh super monogamous oh yeah
monica was awesome
another show it's really good yeah
ethically good i mean it made me get
into racing doing pit stops
i was like yeah that was for me man like
it was
so much i i could blow vegan anymore
yeah you know we're gonna forget like
so many yeah oh yeah but i mean you guys
remember her i know someone already
mentioned it but herzog's why
that was from a real-time strategy
standpoint
you know it was this weird name game no
idea what it was
yeah and you got it and mike you were
talking about soundtracks you can
still go back and listen to herzog's
wife soundtrack and just you'd be
sitting there all of a sudden you're
like
all right your head starts nod and you
know you get into it it's just really
good
and uh that game was foundational i
think people
may forget or not even know that that
game was foundational for rts genre
exactly later in the 90s because um i
know one of the creators of command and
conquer
even talked about herzog's why uh in the
past too i mean
that's just an incredible game that is
weak the theme here today is under
appreciated right it just keeps coming
off
technosoft on it on its face was always
underappreciated
yes those guys those guys made some
incredibly good
games and the thunder force games are
their most popular
but a game like kurt sauce y was was
like
so good like yeah and nobody bought
people didn't buy it because they didn't
understand it because the name didn't
say
what it was right so but that that
company
and another one that they really that i
really enjoyed that they made was
um elemental master was
was a just it was different it was just
it was
different it was one of these i remember
how to
it was kind of an upward auto scrolling
game you know it
you could shoot up or down you could do
magic there was
but it was just there was something like
really
if you get a chance to find it cheap um
it's part of the renovation series um
renovation
uh published it out here try it out it's
it's
it's something it's just something
different cool yeah
i want to mention two other games but if
someone else wants to go go ahead go go
no so shadow run we touched on a bit
yeah you didn't really talk about it
and i shadow run like in terms of
underappreciated like really set a lot
of the foundation for fallout
it's like if you think about it and like
fall out still going today but shadowrun
like the different choices you could
make the team you could put together
like kind of the dark kind of like vibe
like that was like that was an
incredible game i thought
oh yeah and the other the other one i
want to mention is uh wonderboy and
monsterland and one point was
was like sega's sonic the hedgehog
before
sonic because wonderboy
arcade right but wonderboy munchlett had
like these hidden doors i don't know if
you guys played it but like you're
trying to like have to knock in the air
and you find like
the ceramic boots and then you have to
get the legendary boots and the ending
the ending of that game you had to jump
up these invisible blocks all the way to
a dragon and you had to go
like left right left right and it was if
you fell you'd fall all the way down you
have to do the whole thing again
that was insane did you play the remake
stephen
yeah i did i did play the remake i i
thought it was nice yeah beautifully
done
really beautifully done yeah bro so so
crazy the chat is on us they like
we talk
on the genesis and the 3do were yeah
don't count that sega saturn version
outside
that saturn version now we're coming up
here we're coming up we're getting close
checking the time for dinner one last
developer and game that i forgot to
mention and i would be remiss because
this is the game that introduced me to
this developer that
i absolutely love um and that game is
gun star heroes
oh yes oh yeah yeah and the treasure
treasure
pleasure treasure the aptly named
treasure um
gun star heroes to this day i think
stands as one of the best
cooperative 2d yes action games running
on yeah run and gun action games an
absolutely beautiful game i mean
to the point like the genesis almost
couldn't handle it
with all the stuff oh it had that
classic slow down
yeah it was helpful it was helpful in
certain parts of the game
um but we'll talk more about treasure
during the saturn uh
yeah period but yeah i love that game
what about if you're talking about
sega cd man you i would assume do you
know you know i can't speak to it too
much i know someone hit us up on twitter
and said make sure you talk about
how sewer shark was uh terrible
are we there yet i mean because we're
still i mean last quarter
yeah we have to talk about just
at the time which was controversial
genesis having
mortal kombat with blood in it mm-hmm
yeah versus the superintendent
that was a difference maker that that
made people go to the console because
that would be
so much so because at the time at the
time that game came out the time
so at that point in time the super
nintendo had come out
and the super nintendo had streets
fighter 2
and that was exclusive to their system
for a long time until hyper fighting
correct and so everybody on the nintendo
side was like haha
i'm working i'm working at i'm working
at eb games
at the time electronics boot cheeks it
just changed over from games and gadgets
to eb
and mortal kombat came out and
i swear everybody that i used to fight
with
like used to come into the store i was
like yeah how's your how's your mortal
combat now
you guys sweat we'll bleed and it'll be
all right and uh
oh my god yeah that was yes so good man
we got yeah it was
but behind me is the best version of
mortal ko of a mortal kombat
game and i'll get it when we get up to
the thirty-two all right cool so let's
get it
i think we could track we're still a
gentleman but we could transition
probably now to
if you guys want to the um the add-on
right the add-on the dishes right now
we're getting towards the tail
end of the washroom
i'm gonna re-up my water very quickly
yeah we can blow v8
but um yeah the thing is you know it was
a long
run right this was a lot like if you
think how long was it he's like they
they had a jet is at a good run
six years in the u.s a little longer in
japan from what i understand because it
was like 88 to 94 in japan
89 to 95 in us i think yeah
so it was like again so now you know
other systems are coming out
turbo's probably getting in the in the
mix i'm going to think and
turbo graphics cd so the competition is
now super nintendo's starting to get a
little
so sega is in a position where they're
now they're in this add-on thing and
we got i wouldn't press it to you mike
as far as you know the sega cd
and i know that meant a lot to you what
you had tell me about that because i was
i wasn't
rich enough to have it at the time so
absolutely one of the most
under-appreciated add-ons i think i have
ever seen on
a system and the reason for that is you
know
the the sega cd had such potential
when people developed it correctly for
it now
you know i know people didn't like the
the full motion video
but the pack-in for the sega cd had
um sherlock holmes and it was an awl and
it was an
all um it was like watching tv show
and and sewer shark was like playing a
movie and
and and it just you know ground zero
texas
was not just a a plant movie it was
it was a it was a shooter it was a it
was like an operation wolf slash um
it actually it's more like lethal
enforcers but around a full motion video
game
and and and the thing that
that that people forget about
with the sega cd is it had hardware in
it to enhance the genesis's
hardware so all the things that then
that the super nest could do with mode
seven
with sprite scaling yes they had scaling
now genesis finally had it yes
but it wasn't just scaling for sprites
it was scaling it was also able to scale
polygons you started to see polygon
games like selfie
which was an insane game
and and we talk about soundtracks i mean
this was this was when this was when you
started to hear names like
spencer nielsen and tommy talarico now
tommy talarico was doing genesis stuff
right
but when he got a chance to get it and
and
it's the it's it's really funny because
tommy's a friend of mine
that that i've gotten to know over the
last couple years and i did a show with
him
um we we talked about music the
terminator for sega cd
was one of the first games that had a
rock
soundtrack with with electric guitar
that was tommy doing that
the things in fact i just wanted my
prize let's go
we mentioned earthworm jim in the chat
yeah my copy of earthworm special
edition that is signed by tommy
oh that's very cool yeah that is nice
that was when i first met him and and
it's weird that
it's like i talk to him all the time we
talk about this stuff
because he knows my history in music i'm
a musician myself i'm a keyboard player
so
i love a good soundtrack and the sega cd
did two things for me
number one it brought me games that that
were just so
mind-blowing but it brought me
soundtracks that i had never heard
before yes
and when i put in sonic cd
which to me is the greatest to me it
stands as the best sonic game they've
ever made
and i'm and i'm and uh all deference to
sonic adventure
but there's something so special about
playing sonic cd because of the way that
the levels were able to set up because
of the size of the cd
the the past present and future but then
the
soundtrack just spencer nielsen was a
special man
and you know batman returns
so batman returns on the genesis was
kind of a real
not great game right right it really
wasn't
it really wasn't yeah i mean that snes
game was great comparatively yeah
the genesis version not so much not so
much but when they added the driving
sequences to the sega cd oh yeah yeah
it was it just was incredible and
somebody brought up
halo craig just brought up final fight
scene i was just about to go i asked you
about that
that was huge so a huge deal because
number one
that one had all three characters super
nintendo
guy tag our cody let's go it had
just an amazing soundtrack that i ripped
i still play that soundtrack but i want
to listen
and it was so close to the to the arcade
that you know and it added some of the
corniest corniest dialogue
but it it was just that magical thing
i mean the sega cd for me was
just it was it was such a jump from what
we were playing
and man if it just had a little more
time
don't forget this is where this is where
sega that's what we got
if they just had a little more time in
the oven to to get some of these
crazy good games out i mean i've got
some stuff that
somebody mentioned musha from the
genesis yeah okay
yeah i've got the sequel robo elest
and i will tell you it is hands down one
of my
top three shmups of all time wow
for so many reasons and including the
soundtrack
this is mike you got me on ebay looking
at sega cd
i know you're bigger than fema it is it
i
i cannot i can't
it is such a special thing to me how to
say what the segacy needed
and and i'll bring this over for for uh
for brother for brother carlo
italian clowns who said don't forget to
mention eternal
champion oh my god yeah challenge from
the dark side
oh wow yeah it actually
it actually had new stages yes
soundtrack new moves it expanded on the
original it's one of the few games that
they didn't just slap
onto the cd and throw a soundtrack on it
it this this i i could go all day
on the sega cd i'd love to hear it
because it's a
it's it's it's a missing piece for me
like i just
didn't experience it i mean me too king
had said with me
yeah yeah like king had everything so i
remember the only vague thing i remember
was going over there
being amazed like you said thing about
this
oh god there it is there it is there it
is sonic cd baby let's go
but i just remember how amazing the
sound was the fidelity yes there was the
full motion craze that i i had a kid i
didn't think a little cheesy i i'll be
honest
did he gravitate to be that little craze
that was going on the night
traps and all of that i wasn't into that
but i do remember when i went to his
house and i saw and he was like look at
this final fight
arcade perfect you got all three cats
you got the music you got to start i'm
like wow this is crazy
and i remember you know it's sitting on
top and then the later iterations
it kind of steps on my side and stuff
like that and
so again i'm glad you educated his
brother on that because the original is
still my favorite
yeah i like the original the way it
looked yeah the model one word yeah
model one where it had to trade the
front yeah yeah
it felt it felt like it was quality yeah
i mean
more premium yes yeah it did it felt
so much more premium yeah now i'm with
you brother i mean that was a chapter
and then obviously we got a transition
obviously um 32x you know that
that was a thing that was the thing that
i'll be moving on you know
the 16-bit era you know you have 3do now
gets into the space
they're out there you know sega's at the
fire a little bit you know so they got
to do something
right and then the 30 trucks did anyone
here own
a 32 i didn't but i'm just asking if
anyone had a 32x
oh mike's got us mike got us that's why
i brought bike
i do i do sneak ahead it's the rich next
level we gave it right there
yeah i had a 3do i went to 3d i went
through the yo
yeah so i can't remember where my oh
here it is it's over here i don't think
let's go let's go
mike's rolling around the room
give us the history bite all right so
now
admittedly the 32x has not aged well
there's no doubt about it that's good it
was it was so
it was it was it was built because
sony or sony because sony was coming up
with the playstation
sega wanted to get the saturn moving
but sega of america was like guys the
genesis is still still
sally yeah though so they're like well
fine
make a stop gap and that's what sega of
america had to do and they had to do it
in like
a year's time they had no time to really
develop this
it's it's amazing that the chipset in
the 32x
is what eventually would go into the
saturn
i've never owned one oh so it's like it
almost like the problem
it wasn't it also a response to the
jaguar
no because the jaguar came out 64-bit
the saturn it came out after the saturn
the jaguar came out after
after the saturn okay yeah yeah the
dream
yeah i know my nose um and the crazy
thing too was
and this was something you didn't
realize was if you look on the back if i
can
there's actually two outputs and then
the power
yes so you had to have three power
bricks if you had a sega cd and one
says there's one for the city this
had to go into the genesis because the
genesis
many many games used the 32x
to do sprite scaling and and colors and
stuff
a lot of games use the genesis to do
backgrounds so it it it didn't it relied
on both sets of hardware
now there are some games that were that
were actually really good i had star
wars arcade
which was very much like the arcade
right somebody did talk about mortal
kombat
yeah this is hands down the best version
of mortal kombat
ever i don't even know it was a 32x
versus
oh yeah and this was i mean this was a
nice clam shell it had
a very nice manual had a the cartridge
caution
and they had the same labeling okay let
me ask you this
technical question so with the 32x
was there any games that required the
entire
tower of power including the cd and the
30 trucks oh they were still oh mike's
got us
i was just curious because i thought it
was like independent did they relax
right they were all
forming on the foundation of a genesis
so i was just curious
trap night trap used it and there i had
uh supreme warrior which was a
full motion video um uh
kind of ninja kind of game um
and this was this was for the 32x and
if you had the sega cd so so if you
didn't have the sega cd was it
functional
no because the game came on cd so you
had to have the towel
wow if you wanted to play this
particular game you had to have both
they really segmented the market here
they did yes they did
yeah so now all these games here's
what's funny
all these games have gotten because
they're they're really you can't find a
lot of these anymore so some of these
games have gotten expensive to collect
yes
they have i brought this one over this
is my
absolute crown jewel oh yeah i heard
about 2x collection
this is in i have i have taken it out of
the box once
this is currently worth 1400 bucks wow
crazy yeah so that definitive like it
was
that like they just didn't make money
the game was hard yeah
the game was horrible it was actually it
was it was a terrible
terrible spider-man game but it was one
of the few games that had the spider-man
license
it was that was licensed by marvel but
this was made by sega
and i don't know why they made this game
but
um so yeah so that i mean there were
some there were some
decent games on the 32x but there was
nothing that really
that really made it what they should
have done gotcha so the tech was there
i remember virtua fighter i remember
what is it virtual everything was the
virtual series
which is good yes doom yeah i remember
that
the doom was see but you got to remember
i was coming from
playing on pc so doom on the 32x to me
was no good it was like this is horrible
and then
the the actual best version console
version of doom
that had come out before it got
remade into uh newer consoles was
actually the atari jaguar
that one was that one was built off the
pc engine okay
and doom for the 32x was built off some
some engine that they'd kind of cobbled
together
yeah they and again because they were
this was the stop gap so most developers
bypassed it i passed it yeah and
everybody that was making games for it
really was just like throwing stuff
together to try to get stuff
out and it makes sense you know it was a
weird time they were in between because
like you made a good point the genesis
was still selling
the competition now is getting more
powerful they're trying to keep pace
right aims and then it's like
but then it's hard to develop for some
steve you asked me like is it hard to
develop something where the install base
doesn't even have
all the the product for itself so you're
in this weird space and
you know i'm glad you educated on us
like because i was again there's a big
gap
in my sega history and i want to
transition you got to move on a little
bit
to solve here because this is where me
and saul
split at sega plays
this is where cog betrayed us yeah this
is where i at tube routine
the great betrayal this is the great i i
i was a traitor
at this point and look you know as a kid
you know we sega love the genesis love i
just wasn't
feeling the moves of sega cd it was just
too expensive i couldn't afford it
you know 32x i it didn't resonate you
know what my eyes started to wonder ends
i saw the 3d oh i was he and you were
the exact same
yeah like i was leaning there and then
remember stephen we ea guys we're liking
the sports ea makes the system
so they're bringing it over stuff i'm
bringing it over i got you back
i got it y'all i'm about to give a guy
so i'm now
falling out of love with sega i'm
getting upset
yep and i'm just like i hear about this
saturn
and i'm like okay and solve is in i can
hear he's like
like secretly i'm like i don't know you
know i'm hearing about a playstation
so i got a transition to solve like 95
right
95 i think yes and and now
say decide like what was it about tell
me why you was
invented let's get into the saturday
night and solve i don't want to
interrupt you right but let's remember
that sega jumped the gun yes so so i'm
about to talk about it sorry sorry
dude you're right the worst shadow drop
in the history
the console was set to release in nine
late 95 yeah yeah yeah october october
95
when they presented it at the very first
e3 expo
they said surprise we have 30
000 units that have shipped right now
they're in your stores right now at
select retailers
um and that did not go over well with
the fans with the retailers that didn't
receive
um wow any any sort of stock and even
the retailers that did receive stock
because
everything happened so quickly they had
no time to promote
they had it was just this piece of
machinery that they had in their
in on their store shelves that no one
really
at this point still understood what it
was yeah they had
they had announced it the year prior but
they really hadn't gone in depth it just
showed certain things about it obviously
virtual fighter stuff like that
but everyone was expecting e3 to be
the blowout and then the release later
on
in the year and it just sort of it took
the wind right out of their sails
and at that very same e3 you'll remember
the sony executive machine
the uh the saturn was 2.99
this one executive walked up and said
199.99
and walked away i walked away um and
that was it
and i walked with him that was
that was one of
it was it was one of the greatest
tactical errors
ever committed and it it it basically
caused sega to implode it at the
beginning of the end from
sega right obviously they had a bit of a
renaissance with dreamcast but that
ended way too quickly but
yeah yeah so that's some love though
let's give some tutorials all of that
stuff
yeah yeah all of that said so i i didn't
i was getting ready to go to college um
when it's shadow dropped
and i didn't have the money to get it
per se i didn't have enough to get it
um but to just go going to show you how
um unpopular it was i was a
i was able to get it used
used in like three years later
i was able to get i was able to get it
used in july
for and it was like two controllers like
three games like
uh uh i believe i had a lot of stuff
for for less than it was retail yeah wow
um and it launched in may so and it
launched the mail so
i i was able to play it i was able to
play it for a couple of months before i
headed out to school
um and i went away to school so i i left
it home um
but in those few months like i i really
did
love what they had in store like um
obviously playing virtual fighter was
not the best version of virtual fighter
and they
they later rectified that yeah remix
um and even you know again daytona sega
rally things of that nature like
all of the stuff that they the
beginnings of that
true arcade experience promise were
there
er they just made some sort of mistakes
in terms of how they wanted to market
the machine and
it reminded me of the n64 era where it
was like sort of like we're going to
stick with cartridges and playstation is
going with with sort of a hey
when i when you think about it now in
retrospect it's kind of the same thing
where
this dual cpu sort of setup that they
have for the saturn
was very difficult to develop for it
didn't have the polygon pushing power of
the playstation
um but what it really did well
that i was still in love with was 2d
games yes
and fighters specifically specifically
the fight
they beat playstation in them 2d
comparisons
yeah that was back when i would read the
game pros and the eggs
and they would do a little i'm like the
the saturn versions i have to give it to
y'all
were always superior in the 2d space
yeah with the saturn versions especially
when you you know
and i learned about missing animations
because of the saturn because the
playstations have basically
bases elastic oh yeah like when you when
you compare the playstation version of
street fighter alpha to the saturn
version
it's kind of like comical like the stuff
that's missing from that game
um but the saturn to me it was still
it was still very much a sega machine
the way that we knew it um the first
party stuff was was amazing
and and it tried new things um the third
party support was still there especially
again
for me it quickly became a machine that
i was i went down that import rabbit
hole
big time um and when you when you look
at the library as a whole
in that regard it was a very very
special library of games
um so i i always loved it i i really
stayed
in with the fgc stuff uh sort of
a huge i i i i stayed in that sort of
realm longer than
you did in the 2d realm specifically so
this that was always you you always yeah
yeah that was your passion
for sure so um i i really to me it is my
favorite console of all time
because oh wow i never knew this no no
it is because for me
it it was just like it was this thing
where i i loved the underdog
i was gonna save this for the head they
would say but continue
for me it's it's my favorite one because
it's it's the biggest underdog of them
all
um and there's so much that's
underappreciated about it and again
they shot themselves in the foot right
but the things that they were able to
release that are very special to
uh i think to me are some of the most
unique games ever released
and uh again that that import sort of
rabbit hole
yeah yeah that import rabbit hole for me
and the stuff that you found
on the other side of the pond that was
just amazing made this console
so special and then another thing is
that mike's ready
so when i got here i got yourselves oh
no no we i know we're going in i know
we're going in
i gotta hear this this is i love to hear
this from saturday
so i i went away to school again and i
purchased my playstation while i was
away at school so i had that there
as soon as i got home i was only away to
school for one year
and then i decided to stay home after
that and finish my school here
as soon as i got home that saturn got as
much if not more burned in that
playstation
um and and then what happened was i
started working full-time
going to school full-time and living at
home so i had a lot of expendable income
so i was every single week i asked
kaibatsu i was coming home with hundreds
of dollars worth of games
and and again i mean when it comes to
these games that are justifying this
goat tag sir i gotta put pressure on you
because
one and two um guardian heroes
what about dragon force dragon force
uh the shining series shining force
um what else do we have sega rallies
championships
rally was so good we talked about
treasure before guardian heroes
ikaruga radiant silver gun
road rash now this one and this was the
this was the 3do version by the way
so that's i'm listening now now my ears
is perfect i love that one
that's the one with the soundgarden
soundtrack yeah
um all the capcom fighting games the
children of the atom
heroes but right here first fighter
oh no yes yes virtual fighter 2 um
virtual fighter 2 one of the most
amazing
uh conversions of an arcade game i've
ever seen um
that system was not supposed to be able
to do that and it did it
um it there's just so much there that
just
because of the popularity of the
playstation which it absolutely earned
um just absolutely undermined
any love that the saturn would have
gotten and
an addition additionally to what they
did uh on the business side that
shot themselves in the foot um but again
like things like like dark
savior uh their version of symphony of
the night which was
different to the to the playstation
version um
what the heck else like uh magic knight
ray earth uh
dark savior which was uh that's the
sequel to sort of landstalker
the medic says world series baseball so
of course how can i forget more serious
baseball
world series baseball was your favorite
i remember you were were more arcadey
right but they were super fun to play
and then 98 gave you the polygons
finally
and 98 managed to transplant the fun of
the first two
into a truly 3d game that to me
was as good or better than anything that
the playstation had
and the playstation had a lot right for
sure before i pass anybody because i
know mike's going to educate you yeah
mike go ahead go ahead mike i'm sorry
no no no you you you touched on a lot of
it a lot
i gotta hit stephen up again where we
were we still betraying sega at this
point steve wait where was your head at
cause i was i was over there with the
polygons and playstation i was
i was i was i was a lured i was
mesmerized by 3d but where were you at
with this
so i i kind of did the inverse of mic
where i started switching to
computer games so like i got into like
warcraft and like baldur's gate and all
these kind of games
he's going to get something next yeah
like he has it ready
it's kind of interesting to me because
like as i kind of go down memory lane
with you guys i realized like
uh master system and genesis for me are
still
like the golden age of gaming because
every time you get a game it was like
finding a hidden gem because no one
other than the people that were around
you
like no one told you what a good game
was yeah so like every time you
you felt like you were finding a game
that only you yes
and i think that in a way like it kind
of makes me
i kind of get a little bit sad that like
nowadays there's so much
noise telling you what is a good and bad
game yeah i think a lot of good games
get
passed over i mean there's tons of games
we've missed over the last 10 15 years
that you know just because
you know no one found them or like you
know what i just think it's like a shame
that it happens now
yes yeah for me i i i kind of split off
after
uh genesis played a lot of pc games i
didn't get didn't do sega again until
uh dreamcast but even that was like not
nearly as like
you know the definitely the masters
event genesis
of all consoles really like you know
i've really never even gotten back into
console gaming in any big way
since so that was with your pc okay i
got pc from there on kind of yeah
let me speak about brother ames no we
you know how we feel about those
past generations quiet like me
you know so i'm hiding right now yeah
he's still looking for that
how did you internalize it as a as a
genesis fan because i feel mean you
shared this
very similar path yeah what happened i
nailed it man because genesis was
everything
uh for me and all my friends at the time
32x sega cd you covered it right it
started to kind of slip it's like well
not only can i not afford these things
but there doesn't look to be it's not
even speaking to me you know what i mean
and then if you remember and i can't
remember the details but
sega sent out a packet to people
before the saturn launch like i got
something in the mail
saying sega saturn is coming in may wow
and i wish i still had it wow um and i
was like okay
um what do i do with this and uh
i had moved to 3do uh because i liked
madden road rash was a huge thing huge
and uh there were some other 3do games
you know we're not going to take time on
but i had moved to 3do and then
i had a good call you and bill for that
3do introspective podcast yeah yeah
we'll do that one for sure yeah and then
uh the guys at eb games at the time are
walden
software whatever the hell it was um i
started talking about playstation have
you heard about what's going on in japan
playstation you know
and um mike's face he's disgusting i
know i know
and i treachery
so by time i could afford it playstation
was out in the u.s
and saturn was out and you saw where the
market was going right you just
thought and so i i sold my 3do because i
was always
selling stuff to buy a body other one
that's how it was yeah so i sold all my
3do in games got the playstation
and then eventually n64 you know and
everything um
and i just never kind of went back to
saturn until we get the dreamcast
okay you were like me you didn't even
pick it up either
not originally no i owned one and i
sent sold it when i sold off my entire
collection years ago okay
um but uh yeah i didn't pick it up at
launch or anytime near i bought it in
like 90
or much later okay yeah years later okay
yeah now mike
take us take s tell us tell us the error
of our weight what were we
missing fools you better put that you
better put that zillion timer on mike
you're about to go in on us right now
stay loyal
talk to us all right so cog
i don't know how you didn't pick up a
let's go
i'm going right to your heart strings
right here that was their last shot for
me
that i was holding i was like dude it
was good it was good
and i it
the thing is the saturn
i mean saab really nailed it if the
saturn had released
when it was supposed to the the the
playstation was
cheaper but but there was a point in
time when they were selling equal
and then they just the you know you
when you lose kb toy and hobby yeah and
they and they refuse to sell your
product
yes so so the retail i got to cut you so
the the
retail the shadow drop snafu educate me
they did a limited release a shadow
release to set
retailers yes and excluded other
retailers yes yes and then those other
retailers said well screw you sega we
not
even yeah when it originally
launched in october they were like we're
not taking your stuff we're not taking a
shot wow
now best buy and walmart did because
they want to sell them kb toy and hobby
said no the only places that got the the
saturn at launch was toys r us
eb yes babbages and software etc
that was it and that was that was a
that that was such it was such a mistake
the other the other mistake was the
hardware itself
and this is what drove tom kelinski out
of sega of america
he wanted he had actually gone to
silicon graphics remember that nintendo
went to silicon graphics that's where
they
the the n64 um not dance the gamecube
rather
um kolinsky went to silicon graphics
they
he wanted a 3d machine he was telling
sega of japan
guys if you want to bring arcade ports
of model
one stuff home like sega rally like
virtual fighter i like these it's so big
you need to right and for whatever
reason
they they say of japan felt like this
this
two cpu architecture would be what they
needed because they really wanted to
focus on
2d because people were still playing
that stuff and 3d really wasn't coming
home yet
it was an interesting and sony just sony
nailed it i mean yeah you you put you
put
daytona usa up against ridge racer it's
no contest
bro in no contact yeah blew my mind you
know while while
while i love virtual fighter over most
other fighters people people looked at
battle royal battle
royal when i saw that at least that
and that packed in with the playstation
that was a packet yes
i mean there was it wasn't enough to
there just wasn't enough i didn't know
at that time yeah and it was
there were some unbelievable games that
came out for the saturn
that that came out of sega i mean you
know
obviously virgil fighter um
you know remix in two you had um
uh clockwork night which was
really good clockwork night at the time
before before sony got the
got the exclusive on tomb raider tomb
raider really started out
windows and a saturn get inside and i
was able to actually
i was able to actually find one before
the cost jumped up yeah
wow one of the best versions of virtual
racing is on the saturn
yes you know there are games that that
really
are are are top-notch and
i brought these over because you talked
about you talked about um
the import market that's good let's go
so
i had fire pro wrestling oh my god
fire pro wrestling goddamn yes you got
that yep i remember saw
he brought that oh i felt bad i was like
somebody in it whoever was in the chat
that called radiant silver gun
there you go
what is that what is that it's a shooter
man that's a shooter
treasure awful treasure yeah it's
considered one of the all-time
shmup greats no okay what else strikers
1945
yes okay oh is there an elevator action
returns there sir
there is not ah there is not i'm sorry
wait a minute i didn't even know they
made it
i don't even know they made that
when i talk about an import rabbit hole
you get saturn well you talk about that
type of stuff like old school from the
elevators
[Music]
the sequel did so much to improve on
that
character and the spiritual successor
to afterburner sky target high target oh
wow
and then and then just for you bro sega
rally and virtual on
bye but but but but i want you to see
so this is where sega did it again you
see that up in the upper right corner
it says net link playable okay
somebody asked i think it was miss uh
nix in the chat said what was the
cartridge slot for
on this on the saturn so there was a
couple of things you could do get a
memory card
if you're playing the capcom fighters
like saab was talking about
you can get a four meg cart that made
those games better
yep but one of the things that
transformed
me in gaming coming off a pc like
i would take my my computer over a
friend's house to do lan parties and
play doom and quake and all this stuff
and sega brought this out yeah and
what's the net league i don't know about
that
the net link is a is a 56k modem it's
the prior to the dreamcast
yeah wow so they were already innovating
in the space with saturn
okay okay i forgot to bring it over but
i have duke nukem
on saturn which was a pixel perfect
port of that game and i would play
that i would play sega rally and i would
play virtual on with my friends
and now it was peer-to-peer so you
called up your buddy he had to have
another okay
okay okay okay that was
my first real foray in online
wow and don't forget that sega
was the one who brought an analog stick
it's true
before anybody else knights into dreams
that's the knights
and this works for a bunch of other
games like sega rally works really well
with the animals yep yep this is the
um yup and triggers
triggers that's very cool very cool
you're right this was and
i don't know what this was forced off i
don't know if you could tell me what but
for some the the cable came out i don't
know if this was for something else
if they were going to do something with
it um one of the first ones that really
also on the
and and you can see it on the back yeah
kind of had a um
had a video port on it that did rgb out
yeah oh yeah
yeah yeah well while you could get rgb
out of the genesis you had to have some
special
cables for it the the the saturn did it
out of the box oh yeah
okay wow this you guys educated me man i
i didn't know any of this
look one more thing on my saturn this is
this you'll you'll
appreciate this so mine is modded so
it's nice
see that on switch us
nice yeah very nice very nice
this is my original launch saturn this
is
oh wow this is my launch saturn wow
that's amazing wow that's great i still
play it to this day i got it i've got an
hdmi cable for it and an m classic
salute it is yeah i i made the mistake
again you know young and poor you're
like i don't need this
i got rid of everything and i'm again i
little by little i'm going to start
getting my stuff back because
this stuff is so amazing i'm going to
pay through the nose for it but you are
unfortunate you're not i just looked up
dragon force like if you wanted complete
for saturn
and i remembered it used to go for like
150 bucks was which was a lot it goes
for about 500 now
my most expensive saturn game hang on
cog if you're like me right like the
problem was they were
doing all these cool things in the space
but because of everything
solve touched on the fumbles right yeah
the interest wasn't there i just was i
didn't care
yeah same thing same thing yeah i just i
just i didn't know what was going on and
getting the fumbles and the mistakes
yeah what you got mike real quick before
you transition on to the last one mega
man 8.
this right now is and fifty dollars wow
i i had that game wow my god i don't
want to play that game with yourself
yeah
yeah yeah i know it's a lot a lot of
tears aims
oh by the way don't forget too before
sony bought psygnosis
there was a version what nice yes wow
yep yep because cyanosis at the time was
was a was a third-party developer they
were not owned by
they weren't owned by sony and sony did
not own that that
ip until um a few years later
yeah so wow mike's sitting on like a
retirement fund
my wife has said that to me my wife has
said this to me
the only thing the only problem that
that and and
again saw you and i probably have this
issue together
is these are nice cases but when they
break
you they are damn hard to replace they
really are not found they really are a
great
replacement yeah yeah you'll have people
online that sort of
specialize in making those cases again
but it's not quite the same
yeah i mean like i said it was just it
was a different time i'm glad i was
educated on what i missed
oh real quick somebody in the chat
mentioned yeah grandia
randia grandia the original grandia was
import only it never came to the states
i don't know if it had a full english
translation in game i don't recall
i remember having it i just don't recall
if i had a full english translation or
if it was one of those that we you know
you sat with a fact
and and yeah um because the us version
didn't come till the dreamcast
yeah but grandia was another sort of
graphical show piece for that
the saturn that uh in comparison the
playstation version
was was lacking so the grandia grandia
was a beautiful game no doubt
and the chad said mike is more sega than
sega
will also uh back me on this another
another
stupid thing that sega did when they
brought bernie stollar in
he got into a pissing match with victor
ireland from working designs
who was bringing all of these magic
knight ray earth he was bringing
all these albert odyssey games and yes
over to the saturn
and he got into some stupid
argument with him over i mean i used to
be on irc chats where victor ireland
would come in and he would just be like
i hate sega once we're done with the
saturn i'm done and he brought all of
his stuff
he moved over to playstation yep and
dreamcast
got almost nothing nothing like
this is why you don't burn bridges
that's why you're over a pretty good way
out
uh sorry carl one more no
halo craig said is resident evil on the
saturn too
yes forget that i haven't noticed all
these gems all these things i i didn't
know about
thank you mike and then we we come to
a certain date now i got
10 minutes left by the way i got you i
got you you don't say we go get there it
is
you know young cog is is mesmerized
by a very very aggressive executive
and a date nine
nine ninety nine
but man sega was back to me
sega was back to me and it was that that
system that bikes hold it and
that's what i'm like okay this is my
sega it
it they were so back on so many levels
to me you know i'm saying the
the system design you know the very
revolutionary products the vmu
the controller you know they took i felt
what they learned from the saturn and
some of the mistakes
and then the power oh we gonna get to
that i know
i know we're gonna get we're getting
there might get there so
we're gonna start with aids because i
want to know if aims like
when when that dreamcast announcement
happened
and me and you both went away did where
what was your mindset then when you saw
you
oh i was back i was mad i was back full
they had me because
it was done properly to your point peter
moore right came in
and he knew what he was doing and they
everything you just said the hardware
the design the advertising the timing
was good with it too
even the name date again even the names
drew on youtube
right and it came out and basically said
you know playstation had
got its install base by this point uh
ps2 was years away
and dreamcast came in and said 128 bit
they said
network you know 56k you can play online
and had this
you know the the if i remember correctly
had the one gigabyte
cd drive
and it just um 9999 and little
little known fact i turned 21 six days
prior
nice on september third so it was to
solve point you're talking about buying
your own console dreamcast was the first
console i bought for myself
okay um and i remember i lined up with
kb toys
i literally upstairs still have my
original dreamcast with the receipt
from guys i have a keyboard
i have i have everything that goes with
the dreamcast still wow and i was
i was fully back hog i was i was that
guy like on the street corner being like
buy a dreamcast
buy a dreamcast uh and of course
you know if we'll get to the games i'm
sure but like
you know launch games like soul calibur
was
game changing at the time game change
and
uh yeah i was all the way back in gog
all the way back oh
steve i know you were pc but were you
tempted
we had it we had a dreamcast burger
knife we had one uh
i definitely like that got me back in
soul calibur for me
everybody says little gentlemen i mean
that kind of like changed fighting games
for me i i don't think like i've
even looked at fighting games like the
same way since uh
and yeah i think it was a brilliant it
was a brilliant game and i think
dreamcast was a great i mean it had some
great fantastic titles for sure
yeah uh it never got me in as much you
know as i
as a right definitely the the masters
magenesis are still like the ones i
really
sunk my teeth into but dreamcast
definitely got me back uh
into the console real quick on socal
before i pass it
i was you mention it and everyone seems
to mention it but
solve you remember this like i was blown
away at the time we called the mikadas
the visual visual demonstrations and i
remember seeing the killer's character
with the pole and the oh
and i'm just like oh my
god this looks amazing how long did it
take us to download those codes
oh yeah yo because yeah that's right we
how did we get we got we had things
yeah and we had the ability to
specifically download the videos of the
cottage right so we
were just fawning over this stuff months
before the the console came out
and i think so we had to find one of us
that had internet in the house yet
because not all of us had it yet and
so i think it was cog that had it i had
it i had the files
you would just sit at the computer
watching watching them download and then
you see
like you'd watch like you know eight
seconds and then you have to wait for it
to keep buffering
we just sat there we we sat there for
hours just watching this
like losing our mind over this damn game
it's insane it was
i had to cuz now mike i know that time
is limited for you so i got to be
respectful i want i'll probably let you
go
next because i know you may be on time
straight you know but but
we we know how much this means to you
and and i got it before you start i
gotta give you your props
because you one time i was on twitter i
was a little a little loose i was i was
i was a prisoner of the moment with
other system launches let's just say
a brother because i was feeling the
switch with it i was like yo this one in
advance
you know what it is you know game launch
and just like um
excuse me yeah let me remind you of what
the launch
lineup of was the dreamcast and i'm like
and he's going down the list and i'm
like
yo he's right so mike i'm going to set
it up for you man
talk to me greatest first off there it
is the best
launch lineup of any console in history
it has yet to be on as yet to be touched
i mean we're not i mean we are talking
about
we're talking about ready to rumble
we're talking about
racing games monaco and uh uh
first uh first to flag we're talking
about uh
2k games there too 2k 2k all right oh my
god
we're talking about some cops jesus yeah
they are i mean i thought it was real
life the way it looked it was just crazy
too well you know i've told that story
about e3 right yeah so
si the the reason the dreamcast is
probably the most
special console to me is it also
launched my
short game and i say short because it
only lasted a decade
a game journalism career um beast
well because there's people that have
been doing a lot longer no we're not
we're gonna give you your roses now sir
you were out there you were in on the
floor like at the time what you were
doing me and solve would buy
vhs tapes to watch e3 a month later
while you were out there doing that you
talking you gotta give me a roll
you'd watch or you'd watch you'd have to
look and see what the magazine's
yeah yeah right yeah correct me but i i
got
that that launched i i started writing
for a little
site called dreamcast hq and that's
that's where i got my start and um
i've it's kind of funny because i'm
going to show you guys something i
actually show you guys two things
so you wanted to know what the disc
inside the system was so
this is a development disc for the
dreamcast it's disc
and you had to have you had to have a
special um
boot disk to boot it up which i do have
somewhere
but um a quick shout out to a man that
is
when i say is still in the industry
still and bigger than ever
i got to give a shout out to my man pete
hines from from bethesda software and
i'll talk to him
so i met pete and i've known peter
pete hines for a good now it's like 18
years
when i met him during the dreamcast
times he gave me a copy of a game that
hadn't been finished yet
never came out it's it says self boot on
because it actually was one that i could
put in the system and just boot up
do you play it from time to time it's
it's
semi it works
but and there's a reason it didn't come
out um you see the
2001 by that time things were really not
looking great
for for sega they had this this one year
run
and then you know the ps2 was coming and
it had
a dvd drive and by that and by that time
sega was bleeding money yeah yes um they
also lost
ea because because they wanted madden
to be the de facto uh sports title
for the for the sat or for the uh
dreamcast
and and sega said that's great
we love you but we got this we got this
development studio called visual
concepts and we've got a game of our own
legendary we're all right and and here's
the story i used that i've told
cog before about this one and i don't
know if i told you ames or not but
i was at so this is e3 99 system was
coming out that year
and i'm walking through the sega booth
and i'm i'm on my way to our meeting
with them i that's what you did
you know you got caught up you go to the
meetings
we didn't play games when we went to e3
did we we met everybody all
yeah yeah so i'm walking through i'm
walking through the
the booth and i look up and i look over
and there's a there's a video playing of
the upcoming launch titles and one of
them was
nfl 2k
and receive the quarterback throws the
ball receivers running down the field
and it's like look cool the receiver
turns
his head to look for the ball
and i stopped and i froze
and i watched that video for
another 20 minutes until i realized crap
i'm missing my
like something that that even at the
time i mean the playstation couldn't do
that and to be quite honest
shout out to 989 sports because they
made some good stuff yeah yeah but their
nf their nfl game was straight
trafficking
yeah game day was could have been it
should have been called game broken
there was stuff that was it was horrible
yes and this
was on a another level yeah
god's ear stuff and nba 2k
uh it was it was it was like
watching something that i had never seen
before
and and it just it
hit me that this was
something that sega was this this was
sega
at sega's best yes and even though this
was not the genesis
and you know and even though this was
the last console that they'd ever make
and they would lose out to sony
this was sega at their best and it was
headed by a man
who i've also had had the privilege of
knowing for many years
says dave see what your chest like you
said that's my god before i
joined the left field dominance talk
there was one there was
four people my guy
or more
to this day i will never forget
that night the first night at e3 um sega
had a party
because they used to do that back in the
day and it was in this
warehouse kind of hanger kind of thing
and there's peter moore hanging from a
from a metal rafter what he was watching
talking to the talking
nba players playing nba live up on this
big screen you know
and he's hanging from this girder
we're gonna kick sony's ass and the
place erupts
he's a showman i love this showman he
still a couple couple quick things you
guys all know his halo 2 tattoo is real
right
yeah you guys all know that that's real
yeah that is now you know
gta
the thing about peter moore was he
he knew what needed to be done to to fix
things he just
unfortunately was about five years too
late
yeah to be part of this that man
and i i will always have a have a
special place in my heart as a gamer and
as a
as a as a game journalist for him there
wasn't a year even
you know as i transitioned on to next
level gaming created next level gaming
to do the multi-plat stuff and got to
start to talk to microsoft and sony and
stuff
when he went to microsoft there wasn't a
year that i went
through their booth to go to my seat to
my meeting with them
he'd be walking through he would stop
hey mike how you doing
family you know i had it here i had just
had a kid
like he you know and i've had dinner
with the guy i
i i've i've sat down and and broke bread
with this man
if he had been there after tom kelinski
that would have been the perfect
transition yeah it would have been a
little could have been different
or if he had been there if if tom
kelinski brought him in to help
he might have been the voice that could
have that could have talked to sega
japan
and got some things different he got
things done
and he's it's always funny to to hear
him talk about how sony killed his baby
yeah he got it because the dreamcast
really was his baby when bernie stoller
left
he took over and he really i mean
i don't know that sega would have at
least had the last
push of success that they had without
him i agree yeah i agree well yeah yeah
and you're in the space brother i mean
yeah tremendous story i want to do i
want to definitely want to get into the
games and pass it to us off real quick
you know for you obviously
i i get back into the phone you know
i act like i never left and uh yeah man
what what was that dreamcast for you
that's you i think you build yourself
the fair weather friend you know
bandwagon fan
but um for me i'm gonna be honest i i
loved
the dream cast but i ultimately became
part of the problem oh because very
early on
oh yeah you know again a broke
at that point at that point i was i i
got
married very young um so i had
a lot of responsibilities and i was in
school full-time working full-time but
again i had
i just moved out i had my own apartment
so that
i didn't have as much expendable income
and once it was
uh found out discovered and things were
discovered about how
easy it was to play uh
unofficial software on the dreamcast
i became part of that problem but but
all that aside yes a bunch of traitors
in here
yeah i'm sorry i'm sorry young and broke
young bro
um but i have to say um it was
to to um to old school's point it
it was them at their best yeah in every
way
shape imaginable they they were they
were showing their prowess in terms of
uh of hardware
and bringing new ideas to the console
market that we hadn't seen before
um they focused on power and making sure
they could make the most powerful
machine that they could make for the
time
um and obviously it was a weird sort of
middle ground stop gap they
they couldn't they needed to bring
something out yeah at the time that they
did
and obviously it was going to fall short
of what the playstation could do just
because of the time frame
um but you know when you talk about
bringing the true arcade experience home
this was this was finally this is
finally it yeah
this is finally it where you're like oh
my god it it's
this is what it is and in a lot of
instances it's better right when you
look at
you know when we saw that soul calibur
conversion
um and you looked at the arcade original
and you looked at what you got at home
it was mind-blowing right it was it was
mind-blowing to see how much better
that game looked at home and then when
you added all of like
the cut-scene stuff and the story stuff
and and
and sort of the arcade mode complete
package um
it was it was absolutely gobsmacking
like it was one of those things
i can't believe they're doing this
especially coming off of the saturn
i i you know i was i i figured they were
back for good i said this is felt like
this was the next run right yeah
it felt like this was the next one they
said it felt like they they figured
everything out that they got wrong it
feels like
to you and mike's point right the
dreamcast did
what saturn should have done originally
is move that technology forward instead
of sticking
exactly yeah exactly but um
so many games that you know we talked
about that launch lineup
when you think about like just fighting
games we
oftentimes is overlooked because of soul
calibur that power stone
yeah or stone stone oh my goodness and
i've got both of them yeah they'll still
call for that game to come back
yes i would love to see that come back
um and then you had mk gold right which
is again
amazing yup uh you know you got to
mention the the goat right marvel capcom
2.
oh my god i mean the best the best
you no longer needed the ram cart like
rk's perfect conversions of these games
right yes
um you know sonic adventure uh for me i
was a big uh blue stinger fan
like i loved stinger was great
there was so many racing games like
racing games were crazy but for me the
ones that stood out obviously
high growth under the arcade conversion
uh
one that gets overlooked trick style
tricks style
brick style awesome game like such a
good game
um crazy taxi crazy
yes it was close it wasn't on launch but
blitz was launched and i
had blitz and again like it was just if
you played any of those games in the
arcade
you're like i have it at home now i
don't need i don't need that anymore
no right that was it um there was just
i went and it the funny thing is they
had the third party support right
but the first party stuff stood out so
much like
virtual tennis
yes i mean someone in chat was saying
obviously beat anyone in virtual tennis
the animations that game like little
little weird stuff like
samba that amigo like obviously zombie
amigo yup yeah
it's launched with an air force delta
game wow yes yes i remember
and i gotta do this for boomstick what's
up what's up
what are we doing what's up on twitter
the pen pen try isilon
such an underrated game four player by
the way
four players yes i don't know if you i
i don't know if you have this mike um
because i you know king got the import
right so pen pen he had pen pen
and he had godzilla did not get godzilla
i knew that was a that was a
japanese-only launch title
yes it was horrible but we got to see it
and play it it was so bad
um in terms of racing stuff to uh
the precursor to project gotham racing
one of my favorite races of all time
metropolis street yeah
and then and the first time i got to
play again going back to the fighting
games you didn't need a ram card anymore
the fighting games were perfect
um when i put on garu mark of the wolves
oh
it is it is their street fighter 3 yeah
that's fine um in terms of animation and
how good that game to this day
those games are untouchable in terms of
beautiful 2d sprite work um
and the amount of frames of animation in
those games
are it's just it's crazy to see um
i love the console i love this console
yeah
i'll jump in real quick um you guys
nailed all the major ones that i was
gonna take
oh oh one thing quickly what's up but
they broke my heart when it came to
baseball
yeah yeah yeah yeah baseball wasn't that
good i remember that this is a quick i'm
sorry before i give it go ahead
because you're you're going to say what
a problem my problem is when we
first saw the original world series
baseball that was coming to the
to the pedro on the cover pedro on the
cover
they showed you the seams of the
baseball
and the stitching on the glove and they
they focused on all this stuff and i'm
like
i'm about to get the greatest baseball
simulator
ever the bait and switch what what it
was the biggest bait and switch
and i've ever seen in my life so there
was a ver there was a baseball game i
don't even think it was world series
baseball it might have been maybe the
arcade version
that was very arcadey in how it played
um that turned out to be the game that
they
they that they put the world series
baseball moniker on
um it was so bad okay so
you yeah one one it was auto fielding
oh no you could build yourself you could
not
feel it oh
okay so cog and i went out today this
game released to go purchase it right
go to eb games on 34th street
and there's only one copy left cog
walked in the store first
it goes to cog right so the guy behind
the counter is like
i haven't i have a copy for myself i
took you know i i reserved the copy
and he said but you know what if you go
buy me breakfast
i'll show you my story sounds familiar
now yes so i go
and get him a mcdonald's breakfast i'm
like here he goes here you go
he sells me the game i'm so excited
because i think i got over i got my game
yeah he knew he was doing
so we get it home and a few hours after
playing i called cog and i'm like
this is the most beautiful piece of crap
does it look gorgeous but again like i
said you can't feel it on your own you
could throw
only when it came to hitting hitting you
didn't press the button to swing
you press the trigger to load up the
swing
and charge up yeah and then and then you
released it to swing
i said well there's no check swing
there's
you let go and you had to hit the
trigger again again with the check swing
detection yeah um they they broke my
heart when it came to baseball they
tried to fix it with the later
iterations but they weren't
good baseball games no they weren't um
so that that's just that
they broke yeah they killed me well for
me luckily you were more passionate on
the baseball side to me at that time
so for me you know the the visual
concept games
like mike said like there was nothing
like that
that you had the graphical fidelity you
had
all i mean the thing looked like a
television production
and but people forget the importance of
the vmu during that time
because your buddy that was the thing
you played mad and you played these
games
exactly oh there we go
like to be able to see your plays on
your own controller in the competitive
space oh my goodness a big deal because
we all had the friend that is looking
right at this place screen cheaters
you didn't have to put king on blast
it was okay but we all had that guy
and i'm just like it just made it you
know it just added a level of strategy
and
i'm a little bad at the um thing because
i
almost wanted them to go further and
iterate because i thought the potential
of that little device that you put in
the controller was so
revolutionary and things you could do
with shout out to the chat of tamagotchi
yeah
like there was so many things that you
could do with it i just pushed
loading up the ko in in sonic adventure
and then take i used to take that thing
to work it used to
throw my little camera you just have to
feed it
bring it back into that thanks yeah it
was revolutionary and the last one i
said
from attack point you know like he's
like mike already said you know
was it windows ce as a yes as a base os
and then the the the modem right did
they have the attachment 56 oh there we
go yeah okay
so it's a big deal at the times right
56. it was
actually what what this is
because this was pre um pre xbox
right this was a broadband that's a
broadband adapter
for broadband yep because
right before right before the dreamcast
kind of went out their last ditch effort
to kind of get everybody together and
and show this thing off with seganet
and that was their online service that
was like 20 bucks a month or something
like that
it was um but you could play you know
you
you now you now dialed into a servers
instead of peer-to-peer and it made
things better and it worked
sega net worked there were games that
you wouldn't think
you wouldn't i play quake arena all the
time yes
yeah that's so funny story people got
tired of playing me in quake arena
because i also have oh you want to go
keyboard
oh no
[Laughter]
um i do have to wrap up
um and don't forget by the way the other
things that came
the the microphone yes yes for
c-man and uh and and the light gun
which is yo i was i was getting ready to
say it mike a
confidential mission
oh yeah no you guys nailed everything i
don't have to do too much
i was gonna say the light gun and
remember again sega had that arcade
presence for light gun games
and being able to play those it was
that's gone nowadays right i mean i
don't really see that the other thing
that
dreamcast doesn't get uh enough credit
for are shmups i'm a huge shmup guy
and so one of the big ones i've always
loved this is a legendary game if you're
a schmub fan it's mars matrix i don't
know
um i just looked on ebay this thing's
like 250 dollars
um but they had some amazing shmups so
and then the only other story i was
going to tell
super super fast you guys got to wrap
this nfl 2k1
we all share that right so to mike's
point as
i got on the broadband segonet and
everything and no joke this is one of
those early online stories where
i used to play nfl k21 every night
niners representing cool
[Laughter]
and uh i played against this one guy and
he was just super friendly right and we
started chatting at the time
we literally just from 2k1 he lived in
florida i was up in delaware
we stayed friends for like 15 years
wow that's awesome it carried over to
xbox live eventually
right and we i lost track of them maybe
like five years ago now but we stayed
friends forever from just playing nfl
2k1
like i got you know i was getting
married he had a kid like
you know our lives just kind of grew
together so dreamcast was again
sega just paved the way for these
experiences
that you know guys like us of course
appreciate it but i think the industry
as a whole
needs to put some respect on sega's name
oh what they did
yes for the industry because they really
did do so many innovative things that uh
are taken for granted nowadays
yeah no absolutely absolutely i mean
listen this is
it's been a lot of fun it's a lot of fun
you guys been great yeah
take me down memory lane we could you
know theoretically we
continue to go on you know all right so
so aims is going to host
part three on cause we do i did one and
you did one yeah
let's go yeah we could really do an
entire show on each
one each one yeah we really try to pack
as much as we could you know against
luke you guys
this is a lot of fun but before we go
before we go each one of you
i think we've alluded to it earlier
which
generation which sega console
you gotta pick one of your children mike
which one are you picking as your
golden era for you your favorite sega
console
that's unfair i can't do it gotta pick
from your kids man super tough
let's go yeah between matt for me
between master system and genesis is
damn near impossible
so um i will say if honestly if i had to
pick one you'd gun to my head i'd
probably say genesis
okay um because genesis had the longer
life it brought more to the industry
more great experiences
all this but master systems always
special because it's what really got me
into yeah we completely invested in the
gaming for life
but genesis as a platform is i think
i know everyone's dreamcast so many sega
guys think dreamcast is the best but i
think for me genesis will
always be sega's best okay platform so
we got one genesis vote i need mike
i'm very curious with mike like he's
been through
almost every generation he's got the
history we got the sadder love
and there's always been some specialness
to each one of them
mike's about to accidentally disconnect
before he had it yeah i'm
making him choose between his children
i might i i'm gonna it's it's by a slim
margin but i'm gonna say sega cd
wow there are so many things that the
sega cd introduced for me
and and again i'm i'm a musician so that
that music
aspect was something at the time as much
as i loved my dreamcast the dreamcast
did a lot for me
professionally the sega cd really was
was probably my favorite system okay
well we're counting that for genesis
we're gonna count that for you i'm gonna
let him yeah
man you and i grew closer today
absolutely brothers in arms here
absolutely [ __ ] thank you for having me
on steve it's great to meet you i will
uh
i'll find you and let you know how uh
how on to the end is yeah
and uh and ainsley my my sega brother in
arms too
always a pleasure you guys are awesome
uh thank you everybody in the chat and
and lord tell the people where they can
find you before you go tell people
sure so the original next level gaming
just look up next level gaming on uh
youtube it's uh you know we do us
we do a thursday night show uh once a
week and then um i put out various
content
stuff like that a lot of retro stuff and
uh
yeah it's uh we have a lot of fun talk
some games and uh
i got an excellent crew with me so
fastback hdk
that's that hdk enjoy your day thank you
for giving us the thank you
guys for an hour and a half putting all
these games back
thank you for that do me a favor before
you guys wrap up somebody say something
nice about the xbox
collection yeah it was beautiful i was
gonna transition and say that most sega
kid
the spiritual successor for them was
xbox strategy yeah absolutely exactly
yeah and we didn't even mention how dare
you
i think i know the answer no i'm going
i'm going master system although i think
actually
i think i think genesis is actually uh
definitely a better system in terms of
how it's sold in the variety of games
but i think for me
master system those games i i like want
to go play again and again and again and
i think it's hard to beat nostalgia but
it's like if i had to pick star wars
like i like new hope better than empire
okay you know empire is a better movie
but i
i you know that's kind of yeah yeah yeah
okay okay
i respect it listen i i know how i feel
about man's system so i i
get it and and both you and aids make
good points in reference to
the introduction you know and and being
mesmerized by that console that's what
really
got me into it i'll get to mine later
but i'll do last but
soff you said some a very controversial
statement earlier
now that all of this is finished are we
standing on that square first 100
like listen for me in my mind best is
dreamcast best for but for me
that the saturn the saturn and it's
always going to be the saturn because
that was it that was when i i
started engaging with games differently
than i ever had before
and a lot of it is because i had to seek
out
saturn was big in japan right i had so i
had to seek out
where the where the machine was popular
to really get a full scope of
of the stuff that it was bringing to
market and
the funny thing is that i did the same
exact thing with playstation at the same
exact time
um and nintendo as well so it opened up
my mind to all of the
these import games and stuff that we
were never going to get here
and it kind of gave me a broader view of
what you know gaming could be
um so and and for me that just that
saturn
did that for me um and i just i i
refused i refused to
i refused to look the other way i loved
my playstation loyal brother you stood
on your screen
i'll give you that that sound man i got
so much joy out of something
being good on a playstation on the
saturn per se
as opposed to the playstation like when
something was good on the saturn i was
like
yes see the way you treat
saturn is the way i treat mass system
versus nes at the time you know that
yeah
your perspective on it listen i respect
you you you rocked with it i can't
really comment because i didn't have
it so i can't really you know say i
can't you know say disparage look this
was tough
you know instinctually i wanted to say
dreamcast instinctually because i felt
that was the pinnacle them at their most
potential
you know the future looked bright we
didn't know the wheels were going to
fall out so quickly
you know so that was but i got to go
with aims because
and i wanted to leave with steven too
because mass system got me in the game
i told you that's true yeah it's so hard
it's so hard because i'm looking at that
sister
such a beautiful look at that it's sexy
it's just like it it just
feels like like you said like a premium
product and i have so many premium
experiences with it but i just can't
deny the longevity of genesis i can't
deny
them with the right marketing at the
right time the power the diversity of
lineup and
it just lasted so long so many memories
and
um yeah man genesis was something
something special for me so that that's
where
it's gonna end for me but yeah this is
this is a great retrospective guys i i
appreciate you guys spreading some time
and uh let's do some outros get you guys
out here to your respective families
okay
let's get the developer himself stephen
dancing the legend two ton studios
where can you find people find you and
give us the exclusive new game that
you're working on
right now
we're gonna uh twitter is probably the
best place to
to hit me up uh just two tons of views
numerical two ton studios
and uh new game who knows we're having
fun come up with ideas but uh
nothing to say yet listen you've earned
the rest brother if if eddie and chad
have not
played until the end still in game pass
sir right for the xbox yeah yeah until
the end of the year yeah yeah so get it
if you haven't played it in game pass go
check it out
you've seen the history see a lot of his
inspirations that we talked about
play this game man really really cool
game and thank you brother for taking
the time out
so what happened oh it's a lot of fun i
had blasphemous i had somebody called
zillion
i was like oh it's on master system was
love today
yeah and of course my man easily voted
season gaming the big cass
my guy one of my what are good friends
in the industry man just really i love
the what what you do how you do it
professional manner you do it you always
carry yourself well
and you're good you're good for gaming
man you're good for the coaches so it's
always good to be able to work with you
and do stuff where can the fine people
find you what you got going we always
appreciate it man thank you very much
um you know it's reciprocal uh you and
you and saul are just brothers out here
so uh really appreciate you
uh inviting me i love the conversation
we could have kept going all night i
know
um i just thought of another zillion
story i didn't even get to tell we'll do
it sometimes
damn i almost won it now i was like i
want you to kind of tell it now
come on oh you got to go you got to go
you get it i don't have to go no bro i
want the zillion story come on real
quick
because we got zillion brothers here but
this is no joke i didn't realize i get
to say it but zillion
it was one of those games that came home
from kb right didn't know what it was to
steven's point it's like what the hell
is this game
i start playing it and you realize you
have to have the four codes for every
room right
can't remember them i'm trying to play
so my mom i told you my mom's a
sweetheart
um she was single mother i was my
siblings are older so it was you know i
was with her all the time
so no joke she would sit next to me we
only had one tv
and i would play it and she would sit
next to me with pen and paper
and as i got every code she would
she would draw it and she'd and then
you'd have to put in the codes and she'd
be like okay here they are and we
literally
to this day wow how old am i 36 years
later she comes to visit me on christmas
usually um
we she still remembers we still joke
about it that's so cool great
oh those codes were so i meant
everything yeah absolutely
that's a cool that's a touchy story
we'll be working together yeah that's
why i never forget zillion because it's
always there zillion two were that
launched
she bought it for me thinking i think
like yeah was gonna happen so you guys
really hated it yeah and i was like
what the hell is what is this oh yeah we
didn't even talk about how upset it like
graphically was good it was a complete
game side school hard as hell
it transformed into a robot it was just
it was all over the place like i hated
it i hated it
i think it was just so different than
zillion that's what it was like
if it came out on its own and had no
maybe maybe we could have liked it but
it's just like
you expected zillion two not like some
totally different games
yeah the tri-formation i remember that
damn game but um
anyway guys thanks again uh stephen
great meeting you man uh absolute
pleasure first time
talking with you and um yeah you can you
can find the season gaming guys uh
every everything's there we we've moved
the big cast to
sunday mornings now because your boy
travis is actually part of our panel now
absolutely um fantastic which is awesome
great guy
uh he brings a lot good you know he's
just a good guy
so perfect fit for us um and it's it's
been great we're looking forward to our
show tomorrow but uh yeah just
just find me out there and on twitter
and uh thanks again guys chat's been
awesome as well chat's been awesome
we're really
chatting away also solved by sega
brother where can you find people find
you have the stories you exposed you
exposed me as a fraud
during a certain job i know we got
called out we got called out bad
everybody it was bad but we had to open
it we didn't betray
that's fine all of us have done our dirt
in the past
uh you can find me tomorrow on the iron
lords podcast 1pm eastern time on
youtube there will be plenty of smoke to
go around tomorrow
as we have uh we have dustin from last
damn media coming through
the floor is going to be fun tomorrow
yes sir um but you know you can find me
on twitter go stop iop
bx sovereign on psn and xbox live um
yeah guys this i i needed this i needed
this
bad ames you know right here brother um
steve fantastic to be on the show with
you
i don't i i don't know if i was on the
show when he missed when he was on
when they when he was on i believe i did
miss so i'm glad i'm glad
to be able to talk sega with you man
that was great i loved it
i gotta call him the guru man mike mike
yeah that was incredible michael's
friends mike has
encyclopedic knowledge of this stuff um
and you could tell the passion and the
love that he has for it so it's it's
always fun to
to see all those things that i i got rid
of and i'm like oh my god i had that oh
my god
tell me yeah absolutely yeah um but sega
man sega
they think it's so important to this
industry and
you know modern sega is different
um there's certain things they do super
well and you know we
this this there's been talk the past
year about like
microsoft possibly whatever honestly i
just
i don't care who buys them if they're
bought at all but i want them to look at
their back catalog and to see these
games
and connect bring them forward bring
them forward even if you start out with
just repackaging the old stuff and
giving it to us
you have fans that will pay you whatever
you ask
to bring these games forward so um i
really want to see that happen
and and have them sort of focus more on
their legacy and bringing that forward
because
i think they'll they'd be surprised that
the people that at how many people would
be
interested in a lot of those classic
franchises no doubt so
well well if you want to just get a
couple of super chats on the way out
because i think we missed a few
yeah we have we have a couple we have a
couple we have uh out of respect
uh hold on a second
[Music]
while you do that oh why are you fine
yeah i got it okay mad will
madwell five dollar super chat thank you
sir i appreciate that then we have
gerald mack five dollars to attack
that's crazy aims i did the same thing
with my atari 2600 as the younger boy
never told by my
oh the genesis story
the story yeah yeah um kybasu did that
as well but he got caught
i'd never do that well actually no he
snitched out my sister that was it yeah
he was
he was a snitch yeah he gave me addict
two dollars over that support even
though i'm tired of sega talking
about your young behind had to learn
today yesterday
generation don't listen oh six slayer
three dollar super chat sega gave me a
good feeling i have no words for it
so we have urban ninja five dollars for
chat dream team basketball i forgot
about it
about that yes oh yes wow then we have
harlem night
yeah i'm sorry uh five dollar super chat
mystic defender was the sequel to spell
caster that's
right yes yeah that's it
yes correct and we got nam omar two
dollar super chat salute to my fellow
fellow sega brethren salute sir
hello bro then we have iron mike five
dollars
shout out to sega for having game pass
and the switch way back in the 90s yeah
yeah
it's true it's true very very innovative
yes very innovative
uh then we have gamers play with the
five dollars for chat
dynamite heady another treasure joint
valles two and three
sophias sophia's great sega genesis
games two yes
yeah he called some good ones out got
some gold
uh the rubber knob with the five dollar
super chat i haven't seen that david a
long time morning lords i was a sega kid
had the mega drive two saturn and
dreamcast imagine where consoles would
be if sega was still in the race
yes fat boy horror five pound super chat
if sega came out with another console
next month i'd be there day one
rapidly oh would we uh infrablade five
dollars but
my panzer dragon saga sells for over
fifteen hundred dollars that's
that's serious yes that's crazy that's
great and then we have e murray five
dollars in the chat
the best driving game for the dreamcast
that must be collected it's le mans
twenty-four yeah
he's not wrong it was the real
do you remember you remember colbert
used to used to do the 24-hour races
yeah and uh
it had that level of f1 yeah and f1 le
mans did it
yeah it was one of the first racing
games that had the actual day and night
racing and it had like 24 cars on the
field
simulation pits and all that yeah
beautiful and it had the actual le mans
track oh it's like it's it's an f1 game
game okay wow i used to like goes back
today
yeah and then we have lord metroid two
dollars super chat
cog inserted the sega cart right tonight
good job
we did it baby we did it we all caught
up yeah we're good all right cool look
everybody enjoy your day this is
fantastic again shout out to mike the og
original next level gaming again
educating us giving us all that
knowledge stephen you already know
brother appreciate you that it's a lot
of fun and of course obviously you
already know
sega man we always go keep it alive we
always go keep it alive
everybody enjoy your day we're outta
here
peace